all right hey what's going on it's Bill
Burr and it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast and I'm just checking in
on you
um oh my God look at we're trying to
warm me up here
with the blue
with the blue anyway we got a guest this
week
um it could have been like Bluer you
know what I mean they kind of like this
isn't baby blue this is sort of like is
it gonna rain
blue uh my guest this week
has a special that he did with ATC
called The Killing in Chicago that has
been killing
on social media Clips going up getting a
million and a half views the man the
myth the Rose Bowl tailgate Legend the
one and only Mr Joe bartnick what's up
Bill yeah we are here to promote you
I'll tell you what's up we're here to
promote your special and you got a
Miner's cough or something what what's
happened with you uh yeah I've been sick
for a couple of weeks but it's not
covered Kobe I can handle I've had covet
like three times this is worse oh all
right well where what Funny Bone did you
just come back from yeah
comedy condo that's what my wife was
claiming I'm like no I was in a nice
hotel I got sick at well I kind of went
I don't know Steve Byrne the goddamn
Comedy Jam for the Lemieux benefit so it
was a lot of fun I actually took it easy
though I took it easy until the plane
ride home you know how they simmer like
ten thousand feet and everyone's ears go
I went deaf for like oh we I still can't
really hear on this one side of my my
head okay yeah there's a lot there all
right so you were you were at the
goddamn comedy gym in Pittsburgh like I
said
I heard Dirty Deeds okay and I heard you
killed it I did well after my last
debacle trying to do the Gambler at the
all things comedy I don't know if you
can't really carry a tune you need
something Up Tempo I can't carry a tune
in a suitcase yeah let alone the fact
that everybody knows like The Gambler
like the five lines everybody knows yeah
you got there's like a book it's like a
Bob Dylan song before and after all
those words and I didn't know any of
them he called me the morning he was
still doing the show I'm like oh yeah it
was a I was a debacle you were there
was I there for that one yeah you were
there we did it like we did it like
Coyote Ugly style like on top of a bar
and like the Chicago Blackhawks were
there heckling me it was one of the
worst I wasn't there for that okay no I
would have remembered that
the Blackhawks were helping him well
then there he is you're still killed
in your own way right well Dave Boland
and his guys so they you know they're
they're good people yeah but it was a
disaster I'm not gonna I'm not I'm not
gonna sugarcoat how awful it was
I didn't get it done I have no one to
blame it myself
all I can do is uh you know you go up to
the podium after a loss and you take it
like a man no I had to take that one
like a man it was terrible you don't
blame your teammates no you know I'm not
a finger pointer yes finger pointers
that's a big that's a big uh Joey B
thing finger pointers never win
championships they don't you see a
quarterback coming off the field
pointing fingers never have a ring the
guys that what about Tom Brady he used
to rip into guys
did he point fingers running off the
field though
I think he was more like this he karate
chopped that's that that's less of a
it's kind of like a a uh overall you not
you it's not you it's not accusatory yes
it could be the offensive line it could
be this could be the ref it could be
Belichick it could be himself and the
murderer is that man right here you ran
the wrong route I don't know if he did
that he just sort of would like lean
over him would sort of like uh yeah I I
definitely see uh
I can see that but anyway I I have to be
honest with you I am so proud of this
special to have my name on it I just
feel like it's this yes starring in it
as well oh yeah and I do a little a
little sketch in there
um that I just when I watch the clips
it's like this could have came out today
this could have came out it's like 20
years ago it's like Timeless material
and then with the mustache and the
uh the the Russian dictator
do you got going it's just it
just looks like somebody's like
linebackers coach went up there
and did stand up and I uh I'm so
thrilled the way it's performed if you
guys just want unfiltered like what you
know somebody just going up there saying
what they're thinking which I think is
really something to uh
uh protect at this point everybody's so
afraid that you know you're
gonna say something uh and but I kind of
feel like that's even over I think
everyone's like all right all right like
what did we just do for like the last
five years
we let these fascist nerds who
acted like they were cool people
but they weren't they just had their own
they ended up being just like the
people they were trying to stop but like
they they had like they look sort of
warm and fuzzy about it
did I lose you on that one a little bit
but you know what the thing is is thank
you for the comment but also watching
you all these years you're the one of
the most Fearless guys out there so how
can I sit next to you it's like batting
behind DiMaggio how could it be in the
index Circle and be like my jokes
are pretty Fearless Joe no I get out
there and I sleep seriously use right
from the angel you have no fear
on what you say and I think that's the
whole key of common if you're scared
because you know don't say it no because
my whole thing is I'm not being
malicious I'm being silly so if you want
to take it serious take it seriously but
I mean that's not my fault that
you decided and to go that route and if
you don't like it there is literally 10
000 stand-up specials that you
could watch ten thousand other ones but
did my arms disappear into the
but that's me though as far as you know
um I'm not malicious anything I say you
know I know but you know what I love the
night when you did the thing when you
when you when you uh when you did the
special you still hadn't got your back
surgery right no that's why if you if
you look close enough you can see my
dead leg Yeah so you were playing hurt
it was like deep into the
Stanley Cup run and you went out there
like Messier and I was getting sick
because I couldn't go to the after party
um I was all run down and I flew into
Chicago me and verzie surprised you and
you went out on the first one and I
remember bertolina was going like dude
we got it we got it so we're like Joe we
got it you like I just want to let you
guys down big Saint Bernard that
you are and then the second one dude you
went out there there's something about
like your your on the on the final one I
just love the pacing of it the
confidence you're seasoned and all of
that and it's just such a uh it reminded
me of like the first time I saw you at
the punch line when I remember just
going like this guy who is this
guy this guy does not give a and
it's like uh it's kind of what I I hope
for in every comedian regardless of what
style regardless of what their opinion
is what I hope every time I see a comic
is like just please just say what you
want to say and how it but you know
obviously don't I mean I don't want to
listen to some person that's like you
know
being like you know actually going up
there being stupid but like it's
just being silly and and having having a
good time I love this special I
love the way it looks you guys gotta
check it out uh we got we've been we've
been doing all they knew the new ones
come out you know you put out a few
Clips you get people excited sort of
like a stand-up trailer and then we
should I think we're gonna have the
whole thing up on our YouTube channel uh
in August and this guy's gonna be
headlining around the country it's
actually the middle of September middle
of September even it out with my week at
XM radio beautiful it's your idea the
summer partner summer of bartnik how
much how much more can you do for me
Bill huh you got my dad to the Masters
you got me a comedy special how much fun
was that the Masters was incredible it
was incredible dude the first day I felt
like I was at a big ten football game it
was like so cold and we're all
dressed like we're going to see Golf and
then the next day it was like oh it was
like ungodly hot well actually next day
wasn't that but it was actually a bet
much better day but it's exactly what
you look like if in on television it's
that beautiful yeah it really is like
that bridge it's right there oh man I'm
in corner yeah and all of that yeah we
always seem to end up on uh was it 15
it's a it's got like the uh most guys
try to lay up right before there's a and
there's a par three right after it I
always forget if it's 15 or six if
that's 15 and six I think that's 15 and
16 because then it's no I think it's 14
and 15 because then it's 16 17 18. I
forget all I know that was the uh
numbers yeah whatever
but you know what I did I before we went
there
I watched uh Jack Nicholson Jack
Nicholson they pick it up on it it's on
YouTube the full thing on his back nine
uh on the final day when he picked up I
was like down like four or five strokes
and it was just that's that one he he
won oh yeah sir yeah it was just uh I
watched that one
jacket what'd I say Nicholson I always
do that Jack Nicholas thank you here's
Johnny coming up 18.
it doesn't over the top whenever you see
me lining up a pot whatever the you
think he's he's that's probably the most
frightening he ever was oh the shot yeah
he's nuts yeah absolutely nuts this is
scary for film school I'm like how cool
is your I'm paying for this college
you're watching The Shining for fun this
is great and there's something about the
what's what's the woman who uh and I
just spaced Shelley Duvall Shelley
Duvall is like you feel for her and
she's also annoying
yeah I mean you don't want her dead but
you want her like to go away yeah like
just get in the hatchback and just let
Jack go crazy because it's just
you know what it is I think when I watch
it I kind of in her I see myself
sometimes when I'm just playing
the victim and being helpless there's
just something about it where she have a
bat
he's a writer how tough can he be
he just hit him in the head it's
not like he's a plumber going
nuts he writes right
sitting in a typewriter good Lord he's
got uh carpal tunnel he can't even does
he even swing his ass
he hold the handle
um by the way dude uh tonight and
tomorrow there's a double feature at the
New Beverly Cinema
uh Clint Eastwood oh Fistful of Dollars
and and something else it's not The Good
The Bad and The Ugly
this there's some uh I mean that thing
I'm telling you it's that that
movie theater the films that they have
coming up they got three o'clock high oh
whoa they're playing at 3 P.M because
everything Tarantino does is
cool and then he adds another layer of
cool to it my favorite Clint
cheap Western those hang them high
that's a great one yeah next time you
hang him in do it right yeah I can't do
a Clint no that's a good one oh I just I
mean Clint is just the best he really is
he kills me do you know the one that I
Joe is
um
is a connoisseur of old television and
me TV no I was economy of magic and I
was the youngest comic except for maybe
Suba by like 25 years and even those
guys don't watch me TV plus I could be
70. heroes and icons he's got me taping
Kojak I watched Kojak last night and it
was so cool like I put it on I was like
is Nia gonna like this and she was just
sort of like you know she was kind of
looking at her phone and she kind of
just she goes can we watch that intro
again she goes that's kind of low-key
the and I can she watched it again
she filmed it I think she put it on
Instagram stories so it was it was yeah
I know you've seen them all it's that
two-parter where the uh Chinatown Wars
oh my God they start kidnapping them oh
yeah he's up there these guys have worse
cough than me he's gonna die how bad is
that makeup it looks he looks like me
he's laying in that bed like if it
wasn't you then who was it yeah
um everyone just doing a bad Marlon
Brando for the next five years on
television
great call I didn't even think of that
yeah like every mob boss after that
because I've seen I watch every 70s
detective show after that but yeah it's
amazing the other the one that's now
it's on only once a week I actually as a
gift one time gave you the complete
series on on me TV plus again
Untouchables Sunday night at eight I
still have that external hard drive so I
can I can watch it but I I've watched as
far as the Untouchables I watched uh all
of season three four and five and then
half a season one so I only have one and
a half Seasons to watch that I got 77
Sunset Strip I watched most of that I'll
tell you what's kind of badass is the
last season
they fired everybody except for Ephraim
Zimbalist Jr and it's one season and
it's way darker where it you it was sort
of
um
a little kitschy and and like it was
lighter even though people would get
shot and stuff like that but what's cool
about that series is Ephraim Zimbalist
Jr
um point of reason he was like a Ford
Thunderbird guy and every year they must
have had a deal with Ford every year he
had the new Ford Thunderbird and was the
first time that I saw they had this
option where like the wheel like the
steering wheel got out of the way they
literally did it to show the option he
opened the door he hits this button the
steering wheel literally moves over to
the side and then his driver's side
chair spun around like that it was like
the ultimate in lug I think that was the
beginning of Americans getting fatter
like let me get everything out of the it
was everything but they a mechanic
coming up and taking the hinges
off the driver's side door but um
because of you I've watched all these
all the Peter guns I've watched a lot of
the paper gun ones and then uh
and then I I watched I'm starting to get
into like the kojacks the later Seasons
but the early ones yeah yeah the first
the first Bunch you know they're all
directed by Leo Penn
and he is Sean Penn's Dad no way and
that was I mean just when I thought Sean
Penn couldn't be cool enough I I don't
because when he came over and he bowed
to me like great great Set uh the other
night a couple months ago right I was
like yeah you're big on twos like never
talk to a famous person about what
everyone hey oh and I was gonna say were
you ever on the set of Kojak like how
sweet did you ask him no because I he
was he was walking fast okay yeah yeah
hey I mean that's probably something he
yeah he never here you know my thing I
know how to hang I don't want to bother
people he's coming through because I it
was funny because I was actually going
up to Josh I go hey Josh he goes all
Bart neck and he punches me like he does
yeah and that's I don't even know Sean
was right behind him and that's why Sean
just turned around and bowed and he goes
great set tonight oh he was like whoa
and then shade was like wow yeah that
was a big night
that was some random night we did at the
uh the Knights of Columbus there
whatever the you call it oh the uh
you know it's the uh American Legion
American Legion I always combined all of
those in my head
um
uh they're all good for three dollar
beers yeah yeah I'm an honorary member
over there yes me and derozo have our
McHale's Navy hats they were fought in a
war but we'll come down here and uh do a
show for you they wanted to induct me
because you know my whole family's
veteran so I could I could get in by
that way you know like uh you don't want
to get in that way well that that's like
how George W got into Yale one other
thing but my thing is I don't I don't
need a place
I don't need a place that we play cards
every night with two dollar beers like
that's just a DUI like I don't need that
oh that would be death for me like if I
went if I went back to that like I I had
a few really good nights of drinking
there and smoking
um
you know so now I just go there and I I
do shows for like the troops and stuff
like that but yeah so that night that we
were there there was some Heavy Hitters
there's some big boys you know we
hitters in the crowd yeah we had uh we
had fun I'm actually the last official
person to drink with you the Michigan
Ohio State game
that we watched at my house yes we drank
the Kentucky out yeah Joe Joe uh that's
your claim to fame like one of them
you've sent like a number of people to
rehab yeah a few a few men and uh Four
Women If It Rock Bottom because of me
[Laughter]
dude you are like
I'm you know I think that's why you
watch all those old shows and I think
the vibe of your your stand-up special
everything about you was it's like you
were born in the wrong time or he was
born in Pittsburgh
just stayed in like this bubble like a
sci-fi movie is everything else sort of
progressed whatever that means it really
just means you're just changing
attitudes toward I don't think it's
because it's just every error just seems
oppressive well there is a lot there is
a lot of Pittsburgh that isn't still in
the bubble but it's also a very
Progressive City and it's a lot of great
things happen in Pittsburgh right now
it's a great I would live there in a
minute if I wasn't in this business me
too but growing up in Pittsburgh you
know my grandfather used to uh owned a
bar a long time ago and he was always in
bars and I grew up in bars since I was a
little kid so that whole being around
adults in that era that to me is like
that's that's what life is because I
don't know you know so you said that
I've continued that into my adult life
and I don't know how to be any other way
and I respect people I'm good to people
and just chill out relax yes have a
cocktail have a cigar
this is some good music what else is
there you know what's funny I'm
picturing the bars that you were in is
that brown door with the round you know
window yeah and then like the stain felt
on the pool table the cigarette
machine oh what 100 you know what I used
to love about those places when you go
to a real dive yeah uh you know back in
the 80s we tried to like drink underage
is when you would get there and they'd
have Budweiser on tap and they they
poured it to you and like it was really
like an eight ounce glass sure or maybe
maybe it was like a 10 ounce glass but
it was something that wasn't quite a
full beer and you'd just be throwing
those things back and they would
always be like uh
you know just a couple of regulars
hanging there you know that just for the
like one of the great stories I ever
heard was this guy who who you know he's
he doesn't drink anymore but like he he
basically lost everything to drink and
he sold me he goes dude you know what my
favorite thing to do my because we were
talking about day drinking it's just
wrote I really missed the most is he
goes dude I used to go out
my favorite thing to do because I'd wake
up around 11 and he goes I'd go out and
I'd buy the paper and then I'd go right
to the bar and he would get his first
drink and he goes I want to just sit
there and I would read the paper cover
to cover which was funny to me because
he was just really informed raging
alcoholic and then he goes he would
drink till four go home pass out and
then go go out again and pass out again
and it was just doing that night after
night God would have died but I mean the
beginning part though dude well that's
why Miller High Life is my favorite beer
because it's the best beer to drink in
the morning it is what is the average
like when you you start to get going
oh we've had a couple of good ones do
you remember that time we went to that
I didn't let you answer the
question when do you start
oh drinking I don't drink every I don't
mind a couple morning cocktails I don't
really drink I don't I certainly don't
drink as much as I used to now we've all
calmed down yeah but there was like a
couple different levels my Pittsburgh
level was crazy and then my San
Francisco
is almost as crazy my La level because I
as much as I drink I don't drink and
drive so when I'm on the road or I'm
back home I go nuts but when I'm I don't
drink and drive so it's like which which
absolutely sucks about Los Angeles
what's supposed to get an Uber for
yeah well I I live you know I live in I
live in the woods with my dog so right
and my kids and my wife you know so it's
like you know it's too far 100 bucks
it's like uber it's like ridiculous you
know right you could be putting that
towards alcohol yeah I could stay home
holy
it's Helix sleep the Helix lineup offers
20 unique mattresses including the
award-winning Luxe collection the newly
released Helix Elite collection a
mattress designed for Big and Tall
sleepers and even a mattress made just
for kids
they then make one for an AI robot soon
that's the only thing they got left take
the Helix sleep quiz and find your
perfect mattress in under two minutes
this is going to be everybody's seeing
their AI replacement oh I'm not that fat
come on
my chin looks like that
um models with a more responsive foam to
cradle your body for essential support
in stomach and back sleeping positions
mom models with memory foam layers to
provide optimal pressure relief if you
sleep on your side plus enhance cooling
features to keep you from overheating at
night and if your spine needs some extra
TLC they got you every Helix mattress uh
has a hybrid design combining
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top
it's the perfect combination of comfort
and support
it really got into it huh they're
describing every layer of this Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com and use the code Helix
partner 2-0 this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now
h-e-l-i-x-p-a-r-t-n-e-r-2-0 it's simply
safe everybody well it's official fall
is here if you're like me you're
settling back into busier routines with
the kids at school and Spare Time filled
with soccer practices and seasonal
activities your home may be sitting
empty and vulnerable that's why I
recommend Simply Safe home security and
their revolutionary home monitoring
Innovations 24 7 live guard protection
it's designed to help stop crime in real
time now if an intruder breaks into your
home simply say professional monitoring
agents can actually see speak to and
deter them through the simply saves new
Smart Alarm Wireless indoor camera uh 24
7 guard protection is made possible they
should keep their mouth shut until the
cops get there and they go and then they
just go and your life's gonna suck in
three two one get on the ground
um anyway 24 7 live guard protection is
made possible by the new Smart Alarm
Wireless indoor camera available with a
fast protect monitoring plan the new
Smart Alarm indoor camera is the only
indoor security camera that can trigger
the alarm and instantly deter Intruders
with a built-in siren you know what
they're going to do next they're
literally going to have a drone operator
for when the guy runs out of the house
and goes into his car and just follow
him down the street that's what they got
to do uh it's a physical privacy shutter
to provide protection when you need it
and privacy when you want it 24 7 live
guard protection and the new Smart Alarm
indoor camera Works seamlessly as part
of the Simply Safe system to keep your
whole home safe from break-ins fires and
floods
how do they keep it safe from floods
even the water listens to them install
your way do it yourself in about 30
minutes or have a Simply Safe expert set
it up for you either way it's easy to
protect your home for a limited time get
20 off your new system when you sign up
for a fast protect monitoring visit
simplysafe.com
that's simplysafe.com there's no safe
like Simply Safe no you know the other
night I was out and uh
I was getting from this Deli I got like
some vegetables and this little meat
pasta thing because uh I was editing
this thing and I was I was you know I
had to get something to eat and there
was this woman
and she was standing there with a bottle
of vermouth
at about like seven o'clock at night and
I just I was like you making martinis
she's like yeah I go oh man I miss those
days and she goes what did I go and she
goes one of these is dry and the other
one's more like sweet what should I get
I go that all depends on are you a Coke
or a Pepsi person she goes I'm Coke I go
get the dry and I was thinking bartnick
would love that well dry is for dry is
for the gin and the sweet vermouth is
for Manhattans martinis are dry yeah I
just go for like the bite I like a Mark
I like I like
I did anyway I still do was extra
vermouth like plenty of vodka and
whatever the that you put in to
make you feel you're drinking you're not
drinking booze was that just well that's
vermouth for me is that vermouth well
what I mean you're supposed to put a few
bitters in is that what yeah yeah I
don't I like well you know what it was
over the years the the more I just a
little cherry juice sometimes for
Manhattans my my main thing that I make
at home on the weekends when we have
people come over at barbecue and stuff
let's have the dogs hang out is I call
them Big Apples instead of Manhattans I
call them Big Apples you know how I
drink whiskey and pint glasses
oh my God
mostly booze Rye or bourbon
a little you know about an inch of
about an inch of sweet vermouth
that's it people come over about one
o'clock drink four or five of them
everyone's home by six they're watching
four or five of those
I you know I have some good neighbors
and then that's it you know no one's
there too long everyone's wife's happy
they're home bites you know everyone's
everyone's back home and no one's like
oh you have a great afternoon
there was something about the way people
lived back then I mean everybody died in
their 60s though it seemed like when I
when I watched those those uh those
shows I get this morbid curiosity I
always look to see if is everybody on
this show dead you know who lived the
longest I don't know why I do that but
like everybody from back then like I
mean if you made 70 you were
ancient yeah well Bruce Gordon needy in
The Untouchables he lived so he was like
a hundred in Arizona he lived to like
2001 or 2009 I forget right now but I
was like oh my God
if I'd known he was there I would have
driven out and made a pilgrimage and
told him that you were the greatest
gangster ever on television yeah and in
movies he's the Bruce Gordon his nitty
is the mess you're dead yeah
oh
there we go it's all right you can be
sick you can be sick no no no no no no I
don't be sick do you have um you got any
road dates or anything that you want to
plug because I like I I can't say enough
like uh the good time you're gonna have
if you go see this guy and your new hour
is is is absolutely killer
um I'm I'm playing the Stanford Comedy
Festival uh in the end of August oh okay
so that should be cool Stanford
Connecticut Stanford Connecticut so oh
okay maybe Vince McMahon Jr will come
down there you go a couple people from
the Illuminati will come down and uh
check you out yeah is that is that where
the Illuminati is I don't know
well yeah Connecticut's weird
Connecticut's either like you come from
old money I feel or like you came from
nothing the weirdest part of Connecticut
was when me and you and Tony V did those
gigs because I only knew Connecticut is
in between Boston and New York there's
Hartford and the 95
we were like out in like Blair Witch
country
yeah those are fun those Farms out there
yeah with all the bricks
that was the pandemic I remember that I
was getting ready to do uh SNL and I'm
trying to work on my monologue doing
stand-up in a field it was like
Woodstock remember the golf carts and
stuff yeah freezing it's great but they
were fun and then we did a couple of
those we did like two nights there and
then we did some tent in the middle of
town oh and there's no way that was
covered friendly but it was so much fun
when Tony V who he got on stage he
looked at me because you're gonna love
this and it literally was like oh my God
it was like I did stand up for the first
time yeah but also people were just so
damn excited to
the whole reason why uh and thank you
for that gig because you saw me almost
die at the uh
or the veterans association we were down
there you remember you're like you don't
want to smoke any sticks I'm like I just
can't breathe I came off my heart attack
remember and I'm like and you call me
and you're like you in court were like
you're going to the hospital I'm like
nah dude I'm okay and then he called me
the next day you're like you have to
come back East with me you can't breathe
because it was all those fires oh that's
right yeah that's amazing yeah we were
sitting in that tree fort out in the
parking lot right yeah we were like dude
you need to go to the doctor worse than
this people and you and you yeah you
just kept doing that I'm fine I'm fine
or whatever like and I was thinking like
uh the number you know the number one
thing that I always read when people
right before they die yeah he he was
saying he just didn't feel right
I just don't feel right but any
you know I don't feel right go to the
hospital go to the hospital my
wife didn't feel right the other night
her side was killing her so I thought we
took her to the hospital and and this is
I knew she wasn't gonna die because she
was complaining about my driving the
whole way there
or maybe that was their swan song yeah
I'm like I'm like if you were if you
really had five minutes left you in care
I went through a red light you know
I heard this doctor say one time one of
the things that he learned from somebody
was people know when they're dying so if
well if they're like I'm saying not like
if you're gonna drop dead but I'm saying
like if you did a procedure on them and
they're going like I'm telling you I'm
not like they know
they know and you have to listen to that
it was this amazing story that a buddy
of mine told me with this doctor
it just stuck in his head and he was out
to dinner he's like I gotta go check on
this patient he went there and he got
there right before the person was gonna
you know there's all this fluid
in the neck or some like that
because he had done some procedure on
him and blah blah blah all that type of
so they're always The Morbid stuff
though you always hear of people like
they wait for their cousin to come and
see them or their dad there's always
people that hang on until it's like oh
they wait for their kid to get married
or until their you know their wife comes
home Walter Payton remember Walter
Payton like is like he was just hanging
in there because he felt like he needed
to be there
for his whole family you know he's being
the father figure and everything and she
said to him listen it's okay yes that's
okay oh my God
said it was okay for him to let women
whatever what a thing his for his wife
to say to him
um that's how tough he was you think he
buried him in his kangaroos I know he
was the best running up those Hills
sweetness
dude that guy like he like it was so
funny because he gained all those yards
and it wasn't until they started showing
like his career highlights because I you
know I saw we see the AFC games that
like how would a ferocious Runner that
guy was I mean he could totally fake her
out or he could run you over if you want
like because there was a few times he'd
start to Juke and they would think like
oh he's gonna try to go and get the guy
a little off balance and he would just
put his head down and RAM into him was
just like wow isn't it amazing how
they're just like now running backs are
just so like yeah whatever and they have
to now they're trying to sue the league
to get more money because they're like
wages we're disposable
most important people on Earth yeah they
could they could kill the clock like the
kind of um
I feel like Emmett Smith's record is
probably going to be like Joe DiMaggio's
hitting streak because the like the
running backs are just not going to get
the attempts
I mean like those guys back in the day
man they ran them 250 300 times a year
in a 14-game schedule right 16 game
schedule it's almost like they just
tackled too hard nowadays
I know that sounds ridiculous with it
you have Mean Joe Greene and Lambert and
and and and you know butt kiss but I
just think in those days they hit and
it's like they wrapped them up they took
them down there was big hits but now all
these guys are just you know like
six three 250 they run a 4-3 they say
it's always running into like a Toyota
Camry yeah you know what I mean it's
like and it's just like they just last
three years and it's like they can't
move yeah if you watch like an old NHL
game even from like the 80s you're like
look how small these guys were look how
slow this game is oh I watched the Bobby
Orr thing does Bobby looked like he was
like someone hit like control and a at
the same time and just fashioned
everybody everyone else just looks so
slow yeah oh my God and then like the
like the hair systems that just weren't
available back then so guys that have
like the bald patch here is he playing
in like a pickup League that guy's an
All-Star you know well it's like the old
NHL guys even like when I was a kid when
they were like 22 they were like coal
miners like they were 50. yeah nowadays
you see these kids are like 25 you see
their parents in the stands they all
look like they're so young and healthy
and it used to just be like just old
yeah what is that
maybe that's what it is but I just think
people look amazing now
like if if they try if they make a
attempt but like like it happens
all the time out here in L.A I look at
somebody and be like oh is that his
brother oh brother oh that's his dad
is that that kid's sister oh that's his
mom or is that is that the mom no that's
the daughter like they all look like
I think it was that Forever 21
store there's something going on there
does it to you though because then
you're stuck in an airport and say Texas
and you're like okay yeah these are the
way people are supposed to look or you
know like the Boardwalk in Atlantic City
that's a rough one I mean the left I
mean I don't think you could have enough
empathy for those poor people just
I mean Jesus Christ dude like
that these are people they were people
waddling down that Boardwalk that's the
thing like and they know they're not
sitting there I think they're
happy as hell they still got a big
Slurpee though you're right
happy as far as I was I was fat you know
how fat I used to be my I remember my
sister goes you walking like a fat
person like I swayed okay now I was
happy eating like a fat don't get
me wrong you look like a happy carrying
that weight around man that gets
old-fashioned oh yeah yeah that's what I
mean okay well there you go you know
you're happy when you're eating you're
not happy when you're trying to get off
the couch you're happy when you're
eating smack your lips no I remember it
dude it used to take you three attempts
so when you had when you had your long
mullet right and you dude you look like
I don't even know what and back my my
other house I was like fast I was like
Pulp Fiction Travolta if you let himself
go you would be like we'd be on my back
porch smoking cigarette like hey buddy
let's go get some more beers or
something like all right you go
yeah and you get up and then me and the
other guys we were just sort of like
laughing that because there's a clip
from you back then at the Laugh Factory
when you got like a Penguins jersey in
the bit you look like a like
third base coach in the 1970s you know
like you're gonna come out and
bump the Umpire with your belly but uh I
know well you know it sucks being
healthy no one likes to eat right I know
it's the way it's like the worst no you
know what it is it's it's coming off
eating bad because once you start eating
right then you actually crave it and
then you start looking at the you
were eating like why the was I
doing that so I actually do crave salads
now like if I haven't had one for a day
or two I'm gonna lose a million fans but
I actually do like your body needs a
little bit of like I need a salad a
little roughage yeah keep the Train
Running yeah a little muscle lean again
you know
this Train's leaving at three yeah
that's right this train wants to leave
on time
it made the trains run on time the
people made like it was a bad thing you
ever wait you're waiting for the train
you want the train to come on time
well that is the thing about dictators
is that and I think that's why there's a
lot of people like I love getting like a
Russian cab driver and like they
are so like like they love Trump going I
like him he's got balls he says what he
wants and everything it's just like no
dude you just grew up under these but
they they're not used to like all of
these people chiming in look who's
getting new neither neither neither
style works but it's all what you
whatever you're used to but like a
dictator can get done right you can
just get done because no one can
say no to him so there is a speed at
which that a dictator can work with work
at that someone in a democracy just
can't
um but then you gotta hope that you have
like a like a uh like I thought
Gorbachev had a good heart democracies
work when there's like Italian guys
smoking cigars in the back room that
kind of tell people what to do that's
what democracies were the old days 20s
30s 40s 50s things got done because it's
like hey you gotta do this and that's it
uh yeah but you know what I mean it's
like or Irish whatever
I want to find the mob when I was like
get stuff done what happened was what
the mob was doing which was so
horrible for so many people that they
were intimidating and starting and all
of that yeah that the corporations just
took all of their scams and legalized it
right I mean think about his crime is
politics now it's corporations
and the corporation is the Dawn and like
politicians aren't even the captains I
feel like they're the soldiers at this
point well yeah like in in like the
hierarchy you know what I mean like
their job is like you know like how like
you could always you could always arrest
like I was watching this thing on
Netflix saying the thing was because
they all kept their mouth shut like like
the Dawn was so removed from the crime
that all they would ever be doing was
arresting soldiers right and then
soldiers would go to jail and they would
keep their mouth shut and then they
would get replaced so they could never
get them so because they couldn't get
them that's when they started
wiretapping them they did that's what
they did the Rico Rico lost I didn't
know that man it was fascinating yeah
that's how that's how they got the Rico
laws in fact but what I mean though is
like you know what's the thing that they
always corruption and all this stuff and
you know like well that's how things get
used to get done yeah if you want
something done you pay someone he builds
the road you know that's how bids get
made now it's like oh my God this tax
guy took this politician took his money
from him this guy yeah and things used
to get done now nothing gets done I mean
they haven't got a train you know my
whole lifetime there hasn't been a
trained from SF to LA
it's like that's ridiculous
oh like a high speed train yeah like
you know whereas we were kids things got
built now it's like this person this
person that person it's like oh my God
you might run over some bird that has to
live you know it's like I feel like the
presidents are like the soldiers were
and and they instead of getting arrested
they get voted out of office or whatever
they get blamed for everything and then
like the The Dons which are the
corporations that pay for pay them like
no like nobody like the genius of them
is is like nobody knows who they are
like you don't know like I don't know
the name of the guy that runs Coke I
don't know the game that guy uh the
person that runs Target or anything like
that and these guys at the end
of every year they just write themselves
like I think I deserve a 40 million
dollar bonus and like all the favor I
because we're all doing it's just like
it's legalized like stealing they don't
even that's unless and less and less of
everything but now you're going to see
the scam that's the same thing they were
doing with the casinos that's the skim
they call it a bonus they had the
numbers they're calling it the
Lottery it's all the same
half the things aren't even there
it's like where's it at it's because
academics over no you know what it is is
everybody is ordering like these young
kids now like they need toothpaste it's
like I'm not gonna go to a store
they're just like I'm just gonna order
all my toiletries it's gonna come in one
box
like they're all gonna go away like I I
mean I don't know what it's going to be
like um but that's my thing what are
regular people gonna do though
everything's built up for like you know
we're not right we're old people we're
not regular people regular people are
young people and they're gonna be fine
because they grew up lower middle class
people I mean like 90 of this country
they're going to be nowhere they're
going to be they're going to be in
poverty exactly that's what they want
well that's and that's what everybody
who's ever criticized capitalism says
that that's the way it's going to go but
like the genius of this the same way
like you can't criticize an illegal war
that bankrupts the country that means
you don't support the troops you can't
they just oh that means you don't
support troops you get the out of
here if you if you criticize capitalism
and say some things need to be fixed
then immediately you're you know you're
a socialist you're a communist so it's
this just this runaway train
that is yeah it's gonna hit hit the
wall at some point yeah I just
that's why I don't understand the end
game they want no one to work you know
they you know you get you put a gun to
your head
do your own groceries it's like
everything there's no one working
there's I'm on what do they want people
to do I don't understand what they want
people to do no it's designed to fail
and it's God's fault
because he makes all of these
we're getting this is like I feel like
we're in the dorm room smoking weed at
3am so like the deepest conversation
we've ever had nobody nobody what we
talk about we talk about the Battle of
the Bulge you're a big history buff the
bell of the boat
hey now that's what I'm talking about
um
anyway to get it like back on track I
mean I can be honest because I I that's
why I don't uh
I don't I don't watch the news and stuff
because I never watched it so
horrifically
uh depressing and the more I watch these
shows these Talking Heads who
know what's going on way more than even
I can figure but it's all and they're
just sitting there taking the
money
I remember my kids was like eight or
nine she went and my parents we went to
my parents house and they were watching
the news my daughter looked like she was
like what is this I'm like yeah we never
like we I never watched the new I mean
the news I know there's no they're not
offering any solutions they're just
scaring the out of you I saw a
thing the other day going can any can
can anything save California and I'm
just sitting there going like I watched
oh toddy can't I I dude I watched Russia
collapse they were fine they didn't go
anywhere I watched Grace go bankrupt
this is just a State it's gonna
be fine yeah it's gonna be fine why are
you doing that to people
like why do I need to see that on my
Twitter feed I'm just going there like
I'm trying I I I accept it waiter's
trying to give you crazy too because now
there's a thing that isn't you it's like
for you you ever see that they switch it
on you it's not who you follow I I every
once so I I tweet about sports and I
make fun of myself that's it and then I
just leave and I don't read the
comments
oh that's death okay and in the comments
no but now if you check it because I
always check out the hockey news and
um now there'll be a thing called for
you and there all you see is like train
wrecks and just crazy stuff no I I like
Instagram Instagram I look at old cars
people doing crazy in on like bikes
and surfing and stuff like that drum
videos and then stretching videos I'm on
this thing which now has led to like
because I looked at hospitals doing yoga
they but I never click on those because
you if you click on one of those
things they'll make you look like a perv
like that's all you're into
unfortunately I'm in that uh yeah dude
you think I haven't been there let me
check with a fat ass and everything so I
was like I gotta get away from this so
uh no it went the other way because he's
there he's not clicking on fat asses
anymore so now it's all dudes in their
20s with like kettlebells and every
exercise I see that doing this
or like going like this and I just look
at it going like ow ow my my
shoulders start hurting watching it so I
have anxiety I'm really scared of
heights like I can't you know that
famous poster with the Italian Guys
um on the ledge in New York oh eating
sandwiches used to be one in my pizza
shop grown I couldn't even walk by I
couldn't even walk by my eyes I have to
shove my eyes hey there was no OSHA back
then oh my God
excuse me but now I have a perversion to
watch like the kids on Hover like all
the Russian kids that skateboard off the
skyscrapers are right near them so I'll
look for a second it's like doing a
bumping huh like look again
people just start climbing up those
Towers
like my palm starts sweating which is
nuts to me it's just like I know
this guy lives here's the video kind of
do you really know for sure he lives
well he's sort of filming it himself
when the phone breaks
I don't know but I always look for like
a second tournament looking on the
second turn it they just freak or the
mountain climbing ones there is one
where this Asian dude and this woman are
on top of this I mean it's like the
Empire State Building hanging onto each
other I'm like
for what it's like Tom Cruise level
craziness you know just like at least
he's a movie star like these people are
gonna kill himself at least Tom's doing
it so he can keep making 100 million
dollars per movie did you see the new
one yet
what's the new one Mission Impossible
yeah I haven't seen anything you know
what's funny my wife went to go see
Barbie and I was like I was like I
thought we were gonna go see that
together she goes nah you're too
misogynistic for it and I was just like
I was pissed for like about
three minutes and then and then I was
just like all right you're right you're
right she saved you that's fantastic
why I like us I love Ryan Gosling it's I
heard he sings a song that
slashing uh Wolfgang Van Halen wrote oh
yeah honestly I don't even know who he I
I heard his name before I would I don't
know who he is he's not Italian he's not
on Kojak
was he you never saw the other guys
the other guys you mean the one with uh
Pharaoh Russell Crowe oh yeah no the
nice guys nice guys the nice guys we
talked about that with me yeah that's
Ryan Gosling that high-pitched scream he
does when he gives him the
spiral fracture was hilarious
okay yeah don't say it and stuff that's
a great movie
yeah dude both of them that is that is
that's one of the all-time high level
high level comedication great movie
great movie neither one being funny
trying to be funny I mean just playing
the character hilarious the
whole I Miss Russell the whole movie
yeah what happened to him he just has
enough money just retired
uh I don't know
he put on a lot of way well
to have him play Charlie Brown
or something it's Charlie Brown fat Fred
Fred Flintstone yeah but you know that's
it happening though but then what's his
name uh John Goodman lost a bunch of
weight Billy Gardella lost a bunch of
weight so he can take those guys roles
I think he just figured it out
I you know he's really good friends of
Jim Jeffries I guess he has a big
compound in the Australian he's having a
good time a good fan yeah exactly yeah
he has his money
yeah I mean how great of a move is
Gladiator it's one of the greatest
movies ever yeah Gladiator the informant
it's a nice guy oh he formed he's
unreal he's unbelievable
he really is a great actor
yeah I would I would yeah I would go
with that that's the kind of thing too
like I'm trying to like uh you know
because kids aren't going to movies now
like why the would you with a flat
screen surround sound a million movies
at home it makes sense why they don't go
but like uh
I'm trying to figure out that's why I
wanted I thought Chadwick Boseman was
rest of souls I was like this
guy is unbelievable actor and then of
course he ends up passing away so I'm
trying to think like as far as kids like
where the next ones are going to be
because it was always great when like
the next Sean Penn guy came out like oh
my god well they don't make movies
that's why like you know when you watch
like you know watching the old
Untouchables last night and they had the
chick from Bewitched she was acting like
you know people like Sean Penn had to be
in movies where people acted now it's
like you're just a superhero you're not
acting yeah I'm not saying hey I you
know I don't know anything about acting
no I know what you mean I mean it's like
it's not like you have to do all these
emotions it's like green screen yeah
you're just like you know yeah
different can't miss back and buy day to
be Aquaman yeah
well unfortunately we are out of time
um Joe I love you and I love you too
thank you this special this special that
he made this is your Masterpiece dude
this is the best work to date and your
new hour is even better go see him in
Stanford Connecticut at the end of
August and yeah I got a bunch of shows
coming up I don't have the car you don't
have the account it's a classic the
funniest guys are the worst at
promoting themselves Jesus Christ Joe we
got we're going to get the dates up I'll
make sure demolish puts those up there
Joe bartnick it's called The Killing in
Chicago we got Clips uh the all things
comedy uh website and our Instagram
account and uh we'll have the full
special out mid-september Joe bartnick
thank you for watching have a great
weekend your cats
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
um September 21st 2015 what's going on
how you doing I just yelled that like
you know like your mom would yell down
the street Jeffrey
come to dinner
remember that
when you could play outside
you know without adult supervision
because people weren't afraid that there
was a uh pedophile behind every
goddamn tree remember that
your mom would come out we had like a
dinner bell and you and your 12 brothers
and sisters would come running up the
driveway like cattle
you don't remember that yeah you
guys all just you just the day
started the day started right
your mother would just open the door
like get the out of here get out
that was like parenting back then during
summer vacation they just opened the
door and they let you outside they did
the same thing with their dogs there was
no leash law or anything you just had
like neighborhood dogs they just
walked around
and that's the same thing they did with
kids they just opened that don't get out
go outside and play come back at lunch
right
and after lunch you go back out again
you know and then be all right come back
out come back when the street lights
come on come back you know it gets dark
or whatever watch your little brother
that was it I think parenting was a lot
easier
back in the day because you were allowed
to just send your kids outside
it's having them standing in the
backyard like those llamas
you ever see that you drive down
the street and you see a llama
there's so many goddamn llamas in this
country I don't understand it
they're not indigenous
to this country and I don't know what
how people are making money off of them
you don't know you don't ever see that
in the grocery store do you
you know
Lambs llama steaks
llama shanks
sunk that guy in uh with the
shrimp boat in that movie with
uh
Tom Hanks when he had this George Stalin
haircut Yosef Joseph Stalin
Forrest Gump
what the am I tell you you can just
send your kids outside
all right all right get outside you
filled them up with sugary cereal and
you just set them outside
and then you went outside you ran around
and you just ran into other kids
and then somebody had a book of matches
and then you just lit the woods on fire
basically
I mean I'm fast forwarding through most
of my childhood experiences but that's
basically what you did they just
let you
man that seems pretty cool to me
if you were a stay-at-home mother
right you got four kids you're
going out of your mind
you're going out of your mind right your
husband goes to work every day what's he
do he's a Milkman he's a postman he's
something that has a man at the end of
it right because jobs were for
men back then right
they had it figured out
hey
sugar tits you stay
[Laughter]
you stay home with the kids hey
don't you back talk me
I have a penis you you shut your face
quit your crying
quit your crying in front of the kids
you stay home
all right what are you crying about
did I buy you an oversized jar of fluff
another in the cabinet what do you got
to do huh
you got to grab some white bread
out of a bag you got to take off the
twisty tie that's a big part of your
day you're bitching about
I got to deliver milk to everybody
it's in glass bottles do you
know how much pressure that is
right he just leaves her at home
he goes off to work he's a
Milkman or a postman and somehow he can
he can afford a house
because the bankers were actually
semi-regulated back then
the upper one percent the
lunatics up there that each other
at these parties wearing owl masks and
what and what not some with horns on it
right
walking around wearing sheets
um
these guys the middle class you
could actually you could you could have
a stay-at-home mother a stay-at-home
wife
so you went off to work in your
truck and your silly little uniform
looking like a character actor on Alice
right and then she stayed home
what does she do everybody gets up she's
like oh Jesus Christ right she takes out
a pack of Paul miles some cools
maybe some Marlboros whatever the
she's some Winston's the did what
the did women smoke back then you
know it's so funny there's so many
Comics out there that do jokes about
what uh black people smoke Paul miles
and cools and all that that I don't even
know what white people with Marlboros
Winston
Salem lights
is that what it was
my parents never smoked I don't
know so whatever you take out a
cigarette right so you got your bathrobe
on you got your weight all on
one leg with your hand on the same hip
right stirring yourself up a cup of joe
all you maniac kids come down the stairs
or up the stairs and maybe halfway up
the stairs if you look and then they're
on a landing at the front door if you
lived in a split entry
I don't know
I never said this split entry
you know what I mean
the split entry is the house version of
you ever see those people that have like
really long torsos they have the Torso
of a six foot four person but the legs
of a jockey
you know what I mean that blue collar
body I always tease Rich Voss he's got
that body long ass torso in
these little doll legs right just that
blue collar body you just built for
picking up boxes you don't even have to
bend over you just your arms
almost dragging on the ground
well the split entry that's the house
version of that body
so anyway she makes you a fluff
another sandwich no no that's the lunch
I'm sorry she pulls out what do
you guys want you want Frank and Berry
cocoa chocolate berry
no count chocula Frankenberry or Boo
Berry whatever the you had it
turned the milk the color of the goddamn
cereal you ate that
she let you watch a couple of cartoons
she finishes off for cigarette
Stomps it out in that ashtray
then that's it all right go outside and
play
go outside and play what the did
she do out there
kids are outside
running around meeting other kids
playing with matches right stealing
Playboys
simple
there's no cell phones there's no iPads
there's no overhead
what did you have to buy your kid
for toys back then there was nothing
Tonka truck where did that set you back
talk a truck in a book of matches I mean
you were set for the summer
oh
so anyways I know what the I'm
talking I didn't even get on this thing
oh because I screamed the podcast like a
mother yelling that's right down the
Street
you know nowadays you got to sit there
and you got to watch these little
24 7. make sure they don't bump
into anything they all have cell phones
you know what I mean like they're
working on Wall Street
you know I don't know who knows
they'll probably help start
microchipping them soon you know
somebody sent me an article about this
uh this health care provider somewhere
over in Europe that was giving out this
band
that had a microchip in it and it
tracked everybody that was in they were
testing it out to track people that were
insured
by this health care provider
and it basically tracked your activity
throughout the day
you know and if you were just sitting
around like a lump of they were
like all right this fucker's gonna have
a heart attack
we're raising his rates
and um it's totally that George Orwell
uh is it Orwell what do you make the
popcorn
now that was Orville Redenbacher I don't
know that orwellian I'm gonna
use that hacky think
slippery slope into the orwellian
something or other right and um
they were saying that they tried this
basically microchipping people
out
microchipping people out tested tested
trying the microchipping people right
and that they said they had an
overwhelmingly positive
response to it well of course you did
of course you did because most normal
people would be like you want to do what
go yourself
creepy I don't want you to do it and
then guess what they're not in the study
then what do you do you find some
jerk-offs
that don't have two nickels to rub
together and you say listen we'll get
you a ham sandwich with some
cheese on it whatever kind of chips you
want with it if you wear this
bracelet like all you do is wear the
brats all you got to do there stupid
and in the end they get a sandwich out
of it of course they're going to say
they enjoyed it
this is the thing about getting
microchipped in the future it's
inevitable that it's going to happen
because as much as people are going to
fight it as many people that fight it
and don't want it there you cannot
you cannot overcome the Sea of mouth
breathing Buffalo Wild Wing
morons that are out there
there's way too many of them
and they will walk towards the light
every time all they got to do is
flip on the switch whatever Direction
they want the herd to go in and they
just start walking towards it
they just start walking towards it they
don't give a
and this is the greatest thing about all
of it if you're one of the people
running right is the mouth
breathing moron's opinion is held
with the same level of uh
of importance as somebody who's actually
uh intelligent or informed
you know what I mean
the guy who sits there going dude why do
I give a if they know whether or
not I had a Slurpee or not I ain't doing
nothing
that's just as much right
in just as much say
as someone excuse me who's who's
informed
you know that's when they take the
Constitution seriously and then
everybody has rights that's when the
upper one percent listen to it and they
go hey hey wait a minute don't be an
elitist right
but then when it comes to the other
when it's advantageous on the other end
then all of a sudden no no no where
you know you don't have as much say as I
do right you know I was on a plane right
I'm in Austin Texas right now getting
ready to do two wonderful shows here in
this
This Bat infested Town
um
they uh
somebody had left in the pocket
in the seat in front of me right see
whatever the seat pocket in front of me
this book on a magazine that was just
dedicated to yachting
and uh
I gotta tell you it was one of the most
fascinating magazines I've ever
read in my life
I don't know about the sea I don't
know about boats but just looking
at this magazine
knowing that that there's like people
that read that magazine getting to be
like yeah you know what I'm gonna buy
that yacht so in the Yacht World what I
learned
okay and this is someone who doesn't
know the difference between
I'm going to guess Port is right hand no
left left is Port right is starboard
because you read left or right but they
always make right above left
in a religious way right he sat on the
right hand of the father
to go either way
but I was up front Sterns in the back
port and starboard
I don't know
I think ports left
sounds really quick port
left devil right you you know card
starboard oh that's what we all are
um anyways let me plow ahead here the
whole thing was about the size
of your goddamn boat
who's got the biggest boat and
how big can these boats get so right now
the biggest one out there I've already
forget the name of it and that's another
thing too the names of the boat are just
as entertaining as trying to understand
how somebody has 300 million dollars for
a boat
it doesn't immediately get audited it's
a boat that is just an absolute
Money Pit the second you buy that
thing there is nothing you can
do with that boat to me I guess you
could rent it out
you know to Jay-Z and Beyonce God knows
they're always out on a boat
right
dressed in all white linens
how could you make money off of
that this thing was like
the biggest one they had was almost 600
feet and what I learned is that
basically a yacht cost a million a meter
now we're going from standard to metric
and I've just completely myself
here but as far as I know
that
boat
but basically it costs like what what
Seinfeld made when the entire series
went into syndication all of that money
half a billion dollars for a
boat and then you got to have like a and
you need like a hundred people just to
run it
that's the funniest so even when
you're on it like honey let's just take
the boat out just you and us you know
let's reconnect just you and us you and
us and a hundred other people
right
it's like you're doing an episode of The
Love Boat but nobody else showed up
except for the the whole crew
it's got to be weird knowing they're all
listening to you right
some guy you know
200 yards away wherever the
he is with a big dumb tall hat making
you a sandwich
it's got all this extra food it's just
for you and your wife
um anyways I was reading that I was just
like how the could anybody
legally make enough money
and I was trying to think of the ways
well you could start Facebook
even then that dude from Facebook what
is he worth
let's say he's worth three billion
dollars are you gonna blow half a
billion on a boat
that's still a sizable chunk of your
fortune
you know it was the coolest part of the
magazine
was on the front like you know it was
somebody's personal magazine obviously
and there was where like the address was
supposed to be it was was taken away was
torn off
and I was like I was wondering like
where they lived
you know
666 Illuminati Court
Connecticut someplace in Connecticut I
always feel like the Illuminati lives in
Connecticut
right and then I like helicopter into
Manhattan
no it doesn't make any noise
they got some stealth helicopters I'm
really going off the rails here
aren't I
so you got to be asking yourself well
Bill well you know you're sitting here
crying poor house why the are you
sitting in a section of the plane that
uh has yachting magazines left behind
you know why because I did 23 years on
the road and I got miles back
I got status
you I flew in the back of the plane
for 20 years with you goddamn
animals okay and I got the up
left knee
to prove it I'm never sitting back there
again with you animals I swear to God
I'm never doing it again
you know why because I think I'm you're
too I'm too good for you
um anyways let's get to the uh let's do
some reads here now I gotta type
in my goddamn password
uh what the I hate that you gotta
have some Capitals in there too you know
because then what you know then it takes
for ever and ever and ever and
then well how the is that every
time I go to type in my password is
wrong
nope and I left it on the capitals
that's how long it takes me for me to
type them I'm still trying to do it
and now I'm sitting and see this is how
dumb I am and I sit at the front
of the plane now
that should give you hope
did I do it right no wait a second all
right Capital no Capital there we go no
capital
come on Bill
come on Bill come on give me a winner
give me a winner and hit it yeah all
right let's do some advertising here
sorry about that
um all right that was that was sort of
painless when you think
let me close this no I don't want to
save that I don't want to save that at
all
right so let's get back to the podcast
here uh let's talk football
[Music]
um
what a satisfying weekend that was for
me as a football fan everybody first of
all Saturday night
I went to a uh went to a wonderful
wedding and uh afterwards we went to the
after party we were in a Sports
Bar
and um
and we it wasn't we were on the island
of Nantucket and uh
I got to watch from the third quarter on
I got to watch Mississippi Ole Miss uh
beat Alabama
the dream is tonight
I got to watch them beat them and I
don't know why it is so much fun
to watch Alabama lose like I've said I
don't hate them I actually like Nick
Saban but there's something about him
you know it's just like how everybody
hates the Patriots I get it I get it
we've won too much we're
annoying
you know I actually met somebody that
was you know we were talking about all
that that Patriots cheating and he
brought up some other great ones
evidently there's there's pictures of
Jerry Jones the owner of the
Dallas Cowboys
getting off a party box hammered with
like the head guy of all officiating in
the NFL and I just laughed thinking if
there was a picture of Robert Kraft
doing that how long that story
would last
um
that and that time the Cowboys got
caught with uh for collusion with the
Redskins
to keep their free agent signings down
so they could feel better teams I mean
they it just you know that's fine that's
not cheating it's all good it's all
it's just the Patriots
um anyways uh
so I got to watch them um
lose what a game man and
the pictures of the Alabama fans
when they would cut to the crowd when
they were starting to sense that they
were going to lose like you just have to
respect how much it mates
the look at devastate you see that kid
who's just that dude who was just
bent over the wall
I thought he was dead
it just I watched that and I just
that's why I love sports because
it's so stupid that we give a
to that goddamn level uh yet we do and
um
I love watching SEC football because uh
I don't know there's a level of Passion
of the fans and I know I break the
Alabama fans boss I don't give a if
you win another championship I actually
kind of in one way want to see Saban do
it and win the most just to see just so
I can say that I watch the uh the
greatest college coach of all time but
in the meantime
every time you play I can't root for you
if I look if I was born in Alabama
you know and out and at Crimson Tide
country and I was raised
a Alabama fan and I went through
that brutal period after Bear Bryant
left and that program went into the
and I suffered through all those
years then I could be excited about them
being good again but I can't come from a
pro-sports town and just jump on
the bandwagon but what I can do is
root for the underdog which I
did so congratulations to Ole Miss
um
I can't imagine how crazy you
guys went celebrating in Mississippi I
hope it didn't gradually turn into a
race riot and you guys you know
wanting to start the Civil War
again
um hopefully you kept it tame
you know what I mean just tipped over a
couple of cars
and burned down some old trees or
whatever the you do down there uh
but I got to watch that and uh I was
actually traveling to Austin and I got
to watch the first quarter of the
Patriots game
and um
you know it was just it was just
great just watching you know we're going
to be the loudest fans and then having
nothing to cheer about because all of a
sudden it's 21-7 Patriots after the
bills just walked down the field
totally enjoyed that
um and once again this has nothing to do
with Bill's fans it just has to do with
the fact that the amount of that
Bill Belichick gets for having no
personality
you know
like these Sports journalists
don't know exactly what Belichick is
doing they know that he's figured them
out
they know it and he's not going to let
him in he's not giving him any billboard
bulletin board material I should say and
uh Rex Ryan they always be oh you know
this guy you know he's not afraid to say
what's on his mind that's how they paint
him they just egg him on to keep saying
dumb things
you know what I mean I know for the life
of me I don't know why Rex Ryan talks
the level of that he does but I'm
so happy that he does it
I'm so happy that he does it it's just
like there you go Rex there you go piss
off Tom Brady see how that works for you
how does almost 500 yards passing how
does that feel this morning there wrecks
keep talking
you know what it is I really feel
because his level of insecurity
outweighs actually even winning the game
that he has to shout down his own
demons
um I haven't said that
you know
as much as I give Rex I know he's a
great coach uh I can't say great he
doesn't want a Super Bowl so he's a he's
a really good coach and
um
and he does he has a great defense and I
well you know they're going to make
their adjustments I think actually next
game will actually be even closer
obviously
um it's kind of weird like his sh his
talking made that a close game
because the Patriots rather than just
handing the ball off and running out the
clock we kept throwing the
ball because it wasn't enough to
beat them by 21 points we wanted
to beat him by 28 at 35.
um so actually he's talking if he
looked at the end of the game the fact
that you know
the game wasn't that close you
know that it was that we only won
by eight we kicked the out of him
and then like dopes we kept throwing the
ball
um putting us in a position to give it
right back to him which we did
um
and then you go into the prevent and
then all of a sudden this inept
quarterback who throws the ball
90 feet over everybody's head
all day long all of a sudden looks like
Joe Montana
so
um I don't know I'm psyched that that
happened and um
you know I hope you know when the
Patriots go to play him again I hope Rex
talks a bunch more which you know
he will
which will get the Patriots even more
motivated to beat them I just don't
understand it in these stupid if
you really listen to the guy he's not
saying anything
the players on his team they're not
it's to just stating the obvious
you know we're not afraid okay
they're not going to just step off the
butt bus and we're going to give them
the win
you know we we're coming out there to
compete
oh are you
did you not compete like did last week
you didn't try it's the NFL you
should be doing that every week
to steal Kevin McHale's great quote way
back in the day
when he played for the Celtics I
remember you know they were in some
playoff series and they kicked the
out of the other team the first game and
the semi-oh team starts talking
going you know we're not around
they better be ready because next game
we're coming we're coming and Kevin
McHale goes you should be doing that
every night
this is the NBA hilarious
anyways so there you go keep talking
everybody out there in uh Buffalo
fans my condolences you know what I mean
I know Rex is a very charismatic guy and
you
you wanted to believe him
you wanted to believe him I know I know
you did you know what's great about the
Patriots winning is now I don't have to
hear from shred and Reagan
out there in Buffalo and I hope somebody
sent you this this clip there
fellas how you guys doing
how many times did you almost
say
a phone call with me shred and Reagan
two of my favorite people
in the in the radio Biz here you know as
I travel the country these guys
are always they only call me
when Buffalo beats you know
what do you got you got the Sabers and
the bills you don't got a lot out there
if they beat the Bruins in like a
playoff series which I can't remember
when that happened or if the the
bills would beat us like twice
I remember when Drew Bledsoe went to the
bills
and they won that bet that home game
when they beat the crap out of us I got
a I got a phone call then and then there
was one other time
it's it's hilarious and all they do is
just talk about what a piece of
Bill Belichick is and all that I just
laugh at him so I gotta think after that
opening drive when you went 80 yards
went right down the field yeah yeah your
index finger was was quivering we got to
call them we got to call him hit send
hit send wait a minute wait a minute
Patriots go right down the field
give you all the old right there Fred
three and out go right back down the
field another right there Fred right
another three and out for you guys or a
pick whatever the hell it was Malcolm
Butler's amazing interception Malcolm
Butler right
it's wonderful
so uh anyways I gotta tell you you got
to put Matt Castle
you know what I mean Matt Castle did
great with us when he was
managing the Patriots while Tom Brady
was out
right
so I I still don't think you know if we
go and play the bills again that we
definitely win the game because they got
Matt Castle I still think uh and I know
that Rex is a good enough coach if he
has if he has the a good defense but I
think the great thing's going to be if
he just he just keep talking Rex
keep talking do you know how dumb
it is to talk in a professional
sports League
you know what I mean like you're
actually intimidating somebody else this
is a professionals
they're not afraid of you and your
Nutrisystem wrecks they don't give a
oh you're gonna Blitz
all right so whatever so I got to watch
that and that was very enjoyable
for me
um
and it was wonderful I got a bunch of
tweets from Buffalo fans taking
on the personality of their head coach
and just watch to watch them slowly drop
off after that opening drive
you know it's so funny and then to watch
him slowly come back as we almost
up the end of the game
and then to just watch him disappear
again it was really enjoyable you know
it's like when I was in Nantucket
hearing the surf
that's all it is that beginning sound is
Bill's fans before the game that n Sound
is them at the end
so anyways uh oh freckles has got to get
back on the wagon so I um
I'm totally off my diet
I drank like a fish last week like a
maniac to the point yesterday when I was
walking through the airport I had like
heartburn and everything like that
because I ate stuff that I had not eaten
in um the entire time
I was uh
you know dieting trying to lose the
weight I was drinking beers I was
smoking cigars I was eating chips ice
cream the whole
wedding cake the whole I just
chowed and um
so yesterday was was the big day
well yesterday I was like uh you know
I'm gonna be traveling all day in
airports so you know I'm not going to
eat healthy
so I just was like all right well let's
let's we got a three-headed monster here
we got sugar salt and booze going on
right now
let's chop one head off so it's just
like all right no booze today so
[Music]
um
and I'm I'm doing this running dates
through Texas so there's some friends
coming out tonight so tonight I'm gonna
have a couple of drinks the rest of the
week I'm having none and then in Toronto
I have some friends up there and I'll
probably have a couple of drinks but the
second that is over I am back on the
wagon again
[Music]
um
for at least until mid-october if not
until the night of the Madison Square
Garden Show depending on how I feel
um
I actually think this is what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna go after this this thing is
over I'm drinking two times on this trip
then I'm back on the wagon except for on
October 17th
um I'm back on the wagon until Madison
Square Garden that's how it's going down
October 17th why
why are you going to drink that day
because I'm going to uh Papa
I'm going to uh Notre Dame USC
I'm starting to run in dates through uh
the Midwest to get ready for the Madison
Square Garden Show and uh why not start
it off
at arguably the most legendary football
program in the country
right the Notre Dame Fighting Irish so
legendary they've been on National
Television even though they've sucked
every weekend for the last 15
years they've been on the on the on the
tube so I'm going to that game so
um
and when I get I'm gonna try to eat as
well as I can on this tour when I get
back I'm going right back to that psycho
diet because uh it took me too
goddamn long
and too much to lose all this
weight that I don't want to go
back
so uh and you know what's helping me is
to actually tell you guys that I'm doing
it
because if I don't tell you if I just do
this in my head then I can slack off
there's nobody giving to give me
but if I tell you guys that I'm gonna do
it then you guys can turn the tables on
me and be like hey Bill uh we just check
you know to see how you're doing there
so anyways when I was um
here's another thing I'm done with fish
I'm not eating fish uh anymore because
uh
because there's none left is basically
what I learned because I've been going
to Nantucket and I've gone out and gone
fishing every single time and every
single time I've gone it's been harder
and harder and we've had to throw the
lines deeper and deeper to try to get
fish and this just nothing left
and I was talking to this guy
and he was talking about what are all
these fishing areas
up in New England that people thought
would never be fished out he said are
completely fished out and uh that's
something that I wish they would just
say
um
you know
in this presidential election that they
would be like hey why doesn't everybody
just lay off fish
Go real easy on the fish for like the
next decade let's just let him
come back
there's nothing wrong with eating fish
but there's too many people
let's just lay off it we can
make cows and chickens we can force them
to each other you know we can eat
those
and lamb and all of that but like
the fish you know
what are we doing here you just let him
come back like I gotta tell you like
once we just we kept pulling up Blues I
guess which don't taste good so we'd
throw them back I really did not enjoy
it when I think about it and uh then we
ended up pulling up these fluke who the
eats fluke we're just doing it to
Pat our stats and then brought
it in I felt we got took way too much
fish then we were actually going to eat
um
just so you could have the fun of
fishing it's just there's always that
thing anytime I've gone fishing that I
always feel like there's that Tipping
Point where it's like all right we've
caught our dinner
and now we're just killing just to
kill and uh I always feel like like
a chimpanzee then you know what
I mean I feel like you know we're acting
like a bunch of apes
you know if you watch I hate
chimpanzees I can't stand them
when you they when they do a real
documentary on them I I see so much
sadistic human behavior in them
uh the way you know when they go out and
they kill them another monkey
you know I watched one one time just
standing on the things back just
digging into its back pulling out flesh
it could have just killed it but it was
actually getting off on here and the
other thing screaming and I just so much
sadistic human behavior in it I
I hate him and I just felt like
when we were still pulling the fish out
just to be doing it I felt like we were
a bunch of chimps like we should have
been doing that you know walking around
that weird chipwalk punching our
chests you know maybe I'm over
reacting but uh I gotta tell you my
favorite part of
um
of the fishing trip
other than watching uh one of the guys I
was with pulling this beautiful Bass
gorgeous fish that I knew we
were going to cook up and eat and that
would feed all of us
um
was when uh there was a school of
porpoises
that was that was swimming along the
boat I actually took video you know
something I don't know how to do it I'll
give it to my guy maybe uh he'll be able
to upload it correctly but that was the
best part of it
um personally
it was amazing man watching
those things cut through the water
like a goddamn sports car that was the
best part but killing the fluke I just
thought we were taking up the fluke man
those stupid flat fish I just felt like
I was beating up a three-year-old
um so anyways let's uh
it's uh let's do some of the
reads here for this week
um
oh hey by the way if you want to send in
a um
a uh a question here to the podcast the
where you send it is to Bill at the
mmpodcast.com and that's all lowercase
except for the M's in mm podcast bill at
the mm podcast
um oh did anybody watch the Emmys last
night
um I didn't watch him I was traveling
and um
evidently
um somebody gave some powerful speech
some woman gave a speech about uh racism
and all that and of course the crowd
went crazy
and uh
I I don't get that moment
when somebody black is on stage right
and they talk about how racist Hollywood
is and how it needs to stop the level
like the white people in the crowd
almost like trip over themselves to
stand up and applaud
and it always comes off so phony
to me
like the level that yeah the level that
they're screaming and applauding and
crying and doing all this
it's just like you guys are the
guys who are running the I'm not
talking about the actors but there's
like show runners in the crowd there's
there's heads of studios and all that
it's like if you really gave a
to the level that you're acting like
you're giving a the person on stage
wouldn't have to be making wouldn't have
to be making this speech
I think it's so I think that
they did jumping up and they're
applauding at that level because
they don't want to get caught on camera
and not clapping
you know what I mean and I'm not saying
that all white people are bad
all right I'm not saying that but
it it just it I don't I don't
get that moment
I feel like Whitey's like me in that
moment rather than applauding wildly
should be going like all right all right
you got us you're right you're right
we gotta we gotta work better we got to
work harder on that one sorry
about that
instead of standing there applauding as
if you're not part of the problem
you know what I mean it's even myself as
much as I feel like things should be
fair I don't do anything about it
you know what I mean I'm just trying to
keep my boat afloat right
that's actually kind of funny when you
think about it
when you think about how cutthroat
show business is
the most honest things that white people
could do in that point
at that point would not be to applaud
they would be like wait a minute
this business is hard enough for us with
it being completely unfair and tilted in
our favor
why would I applaud to level it out like
yeah
make it harder for me
[Music]
balding redheaded male I needed
to be slanted in my favor as much as
possible that would be the most honest
moment
the most honest reaction but everybody
doesn't they all stand up and freak out
and this is what it really pisses me off
is they then think that yeah I'm a good
person because I just did that
this person is going through this
they said they're second going through
this and now I'm gonna stand up and
apply and be like that's right you
shouldn't have to go through that
okay now I'm gonna sit back down again
and be white
[Laughter]
for somebody
even if it's a feminist anything to be
up there standing be like why are you
applauding right now
are you going to do anything about this
you know what I mean and human beings
are all selfish and you know most part
you're not
I don't know maybe are they I don't
maybe I'm just pessimistic I
have no idea all right let's uh let's
plow ahead here
um
all right American people in their clubs
hi Bill wanted to ask about you guys
across the pond and the way you support
your clubs all right first of all we
call them teams
all right just to let you know if you
want to blend in if you're if your
government ever goes belly up and you
sneak into this country and you don't
want to be found out
you know that you're an illegal alien
you say teams you don't say clubs
and vice versa when the dollar collapse
I'll go over there and be like
what club you support
put another stream the Bobby
shagadelic baby just start quoting awful
American movies um to me it looks like
you support anyone you fancy anywhere in
the U.S
it seems you support about five teams in
five different sports
over in bloody we support only like one
sport and you keep to it ah Jesus Christ
can you pat yourself well yeah
we're loyal over here really
what else you gonna do over there
the else are you gonna do over in
Australia don't give me any
because I've been to your
country unless you're in Melbourne there
ain't to do Sydney Sydney Jesus
Christ Sydney is like Sacramento
California
all right
the whole million country is full of the
most evil poisonous ever
right
you can't even go there
that's what AC DC's Highway to Hell was
about wasn't it driving from Perth all
the way through that
Jesus Christ all right let's see
usually soccer slash football
um is what you support but the Richer
you are this the sport changes example
rugby tennis and so on those are for
rich people evidently uh for the most
for most people you support one team and
you live no more than 30 mile radius or
at least
uh to your top League team unless you're
a glory supporter which means a
bandwagoner I guess so my question is
are all Americans Glory hunters or is
there a way of doing things the novice
can't see go yourself yeah you dope
I don't know what the you're
talking about
I support all the Boston teams
the Patriots as far as like we have four
professional sports and I can't help it
that we have more over here see the
middle of our country we're able to grow
enough food to feed the world you guys
the middle of your country you have
enough poisonous to murder
everybody in the world
maybe that's why your teams are only 30
miles of way you're trying to
you're trying to shorten the travel to
the stadium so nobody dies
um yeah so the four major sports over
here football basketball baseball and
hockey and uh I support
all the Boston teams those are my
favorite teams they always have been now
since I have a job where I have all this
free time
you know I can watch golf majors I can
watch Tennis Majors I can watch college
football I can watch college hoop I
can't watch it and pay attention to it
the level that I pay attention to
football and hockey you can't even with
the four major sports
like basically
somebody who watches and pays attention
like to baseball and football
then asked to make a choice with
basketball or hockey
like this football baseball and
basketball fan says football baseball
and hockey fans and for the most part
the way The Season's overlap now it's
becoming football and basketball
football and hockey
or maybe some people just a hardcore
like baseball fan
um
you know that's basically what it is but
we definitely have Glory supporters you
call them or
um bandwagon fans there's a lot of
bandwagon Yankee fans there's a lot of
bandwagon um
like Dallas Cowboy fans when they're
good you know there's just certain teams
that are like
I don't know they have like National
appeal
but um no for the most part yeah you go
and people support the teams that are in
their area I don't know what you're
seeing or if you hear me because I talk
about all these different sports I mean
I have to or unless I just want to do
like a Boston's podcast which kind of
limits
I mean this podcast is Boston enough I
don't want to you know
eliminate all that other right
you understand what I'm saying I'm not I
think we just got a bunch of great
Sports over here and it's fun to
watch but I don't think that people are
necessarily any more bandwagon over here
well I can't say than over there because
I don't know what the goes on over
there but um
as usual you uh you're not from the
United States and you did what most
foreigners do is you in a very insulting
way all over uh America you try
to act like you're trying to get
information as you all over us uh
but the great thing about my job is
um
I've been to where you're at and I've
smelt your and it smells no
differently
so go yourself
um
anyways Aussie rules good day Blinky
bill
um no I don't think that there's any
more
well like I said I guess I don't know
how many people are Glory
supporters over there
um
all right let's continue all right last
week you got an email from a fellow
Australian fan who asked you to explain
the rules of American football in return
you you asked an Aussie to explain our
own brand of football so here goes oh
Jesus by the way I should have just said
American football
you know
you got two ends of the field
both teams defend the end of the field
that's to their backs all right
the other team gets the ball
all right if they run it into the end
zone or throwing into the end zone they
get six points followed by
an extra point where they kick it
through the uprights for one point all
right
if you drive down the field stalls
you could try to kick the ball through
the uprights and you get three points if
you don't think he can make it you punt
the ball
that's it that's all I should have said
go through the whole first down second
down all that is too much all right
Australian Rules that's chapter two all
right Australian Rules Football was
invented in Melbourne
uh Victoria
in the 1870s yes that long ago
well why did you think that I was gonna
think that was a long time ago baseball
was invented in the 1880s
there's always that insulting like
like in the United States you
don't know whoa are 1870s people
were alive back dead
um and there's a competition between 18
teams from around the nation each each
team plays 22 games between April and
September and then the top eight teams
on the latter play finals football
during September's September and into
October all right so it's playoff time
winning a game gets the team four
Premiership points and losing it gets
you nothing
AFL is played on a large oval about 150
meters from gold to Gold there really
aren't any set dimensions for the field
of play as the ovals over in Perth are
known to be wider than the fields in
Victoria in South Australia well back in
the day in the NHL hockey rinks were
different sizes Boston had a smaller
rink so we more had like Grinders you
know
physical players and then uh other
places you know if they had a bigger
rink they went more for speed
um and then teams used to do like
if the other team was fast they wouldn't
they'd have the ice be a little more
slushy and all that type of all
that type of you know anyway so
here we go anyways now to the actual
rules
like in the NFL there are some set point
players uh but for now let's just break
them into Defenders midfielders and
forwards the ball is bounced in the
center of the ground at the start of
play or after a goal is scored and the
opposing Rockman that was in quotes jump
to try and tap the ball to their
Midfield midfielder's Advantage quite
like basketball to dispose of the ball a
player must either kick it or handball
it which is essentially holding the ball
in one hand and punching it with the
other a player cannot throw the ball
but can kick or hand ball in any
direction the ball must be bounced while
a player is running with it like in
basketball but only like every 10 Paces
if the ball is kicked outside the field
of play
this is actually interesting because
I've watched the game in a picture and
run these running around now I
kind of get it if the ball is kicked
outside the field of play on the full
on the full what the is that a free
kick is awarded to the other team if it
goes out of bounds after bouncing along
the ground the boundary umpires just
throws just throws it in
what the is the fall
the ball is kicked outside the field of
play on the full
a free kick is awarded to the other team
a free kick what to kick it between
those posts or to kick it to your other
team
I don't know if a player catches
the ball it is called a mark
and the Umpire referee will blow his
whistle and award this player a few
seconds to explore his options and then
kick on if the player moves past the
line I've seen all of this
yeah they all clear out
if the player moves past the line where
he where he marked the ball the Umpire
calls play on and the player can then be
tackled by the opposition if he is
tackled with the ball and does not get
rid of it legally it's called holding
the ball and the and and the tackler
gets a free kick what
don't you mean then the tackler gets a
free kick however the tackler falls on
the victim's back or makes head high
contact a free kicked as awarded to the
player he was tackling
Jesus Christ dude this is way too much
information
this it's still going to go
he's still going here in order to score
a player must kick the ball through his
team's Center goal post if he does this
it's worth six points however if he
misses to either side the ball goes
through
the behind the posts it's worth just one
point
oh yeah because you guys got the two
tall ones and then the two smaller ones
right
usually girls are scored from inside a
team's 50 meter Arc but they don't have
to be goals can be kicked by any player
on the ground in any way you can imagine
as long as it comes off the foot and is
not touched by another player lastly a
Specky
a Specky come
on Jay they always have e at the end
Specky Roy Specky uh lastly I went to
English to Aussie right it's Becky um a
Specky is when one player jumps on the
ball
jumps on the shoulders or back of
another player to Mark the ball
they are named appropriately because
they are spectacular to watch
yeah that's a big thing like they don't
want to say the whole word they just
throw e at the end
it's Becky it was a Specky instead of
saying spectacular
um I think anyways only been there a
couple times his players are often as
high as four meters when they catch the
ball it's about a little more than 12
feet in the air thankfully head high
contact does not apply
to species that's about it bill seems
like a lot of rules when it all written
down but I'm sure a seasoned Sports Pro
like yourself could pick it up pretty
quickly games
um are streamed on
www.afl.com.au who knows maybe AFL could
add some excitement to the dry months
between hockey basketball and NFL uh if
you're looking for a team I reckon you
suit the Western Bulldogs
you love your dogs obviously but more
than just that they also play in the
same colors as your Patriots and they
are based in a decent working class area
just like your beloved Boston uh go love
yourself my friend thanks for reading
and thanks for years of laughs all right
P.S
Blinky bill is a much-loved Australian
cartoon koala
oh I gotta look that up
all right here comes a creepy one
um she said rape I had a videotape
all right talk about going from just
some to to about as heavy a
topic as you could have all right hey
Bill I got a little question does it
sound like a little question dude she
said rape I have videotape
all right this all sounds crazy all
right last year I had sex with a girl
and two days later I was arrested
charged with rape luckily I filmed it
I filmed it all as me and a friend had a
threesome with her so it's all good now
wait a minute
all right so if I'm to believe you you
and your friend had a threesome with
this woman you filmed it
did she know you were filming it
maybe because you filmed it
she then got afraid that you're going to
show it to people so then she did that I
have no idea there's too many
or maybe you filmed it and she didn't
know
which would make you a piece of but
then smart because she said it was rape
and it wasn't that's if I believe you
that there's a lot of variables here
um luckily I filmed it all as me and a
friend had a threesome with her so it's
all good now do you see I have to still
doubt this guy because of this thing he
had a videotape the cops watched it and
he got off I still have to act like she
still had a case because it's rape you
know what I mean I have to act like no
guy ever gets accused of rape when he
didn't rape you know what I mean I have
to be like
you know what I mean I gotta be like
those white people at the award shows I
have to stand up and applaud
but the whole thing stresses stressed me
out so bad that I had to quit my job
yeah I would think so and I've gone to
therapy ever since now I always wear a
hidden recording device when I'm on a
date with a girl I got paid a thousand
dollars because all of that happened
or a thousand dollars in Damages the
girl on the other hand didn't suffer a
bit she was apparently unstable and had
reported eight other cases of rape the
same year I was number nine still the
police showed up with six men two cars
and made my room look like a scene from
CSI well they're just doing their job
dude and as she was unstable she didn't
have to pay me or any or anything or
anyone I got paid by the government
I was risking years behind bars yeah and
God knows what they would have done to
you in there I read something in the
local paper by another one of her
victims
that was also proven innocent was being
hated on by my country's
biggest feminist groups rape is serious
but this is this has to stop what are
your thoughts on this Bill thank you uh
for your answer and consensually
you
um
yeah I mean I I think that's your
situation is you're going to get caught
up in after years of
it going totally the other way whereas
where they blamed the victim and said
well what were you wearing
um you were asking for it what did you
think was going to happen now
you know which obviously needed to stop
that now socially
it's gone
from where they blame the victim
to I mean back in the day they'd be like
well you were drinking what did you
think was going to happen
um
they've gone all the way to the other
side now where it's just like
if she said she was raped she was raped
so
which isn't about what makes it a bad
thing
is the fact that they put the accused
name in the picture and everything in
the paper before anything has
been proven
and I am an advocate of you protect both
people until something has been proven
either innocence or guilt all right and
if it's innocent you let that person get
back on with their life because you
cannot shake that
it's over the second you're accused of
that it's over
you know it's it's complete it's it's
over you have branded that for the rest
of your life and when you have
somebody out there if they're
unstable
and they're doing this for whatever
reason
I mean God knows what a horrible thing
happened to this person that they're
doing this
um or maybe they were born unstable I
have no idea but
you know the fact that you know you get
a thousand bucks
you're in therapy you got to quit your
job and all that I mean uh look
who's kidding who dude all right you had
a threesome
all right
you videotaping the thing
I mean I don't know that yet
wow I can't say you don't wear a
recording device I totally understand
why you would
I totally get that but I would just say
why don't you
you know try to date somebody a little
more stable I mean you're going on dates
versus you know
hooking up
with some crazy person who's having a
threesome and letting you film the
thing I mean right there dude if
you're like if you hook up with
somebody
you don't know him from Adam and
they're gonna have a threesome
and they're gonna let you film the
thing
I mean right there I mean the amount of
red flags that should be flying in your
face you shouldn't even be seeing the
person anymore here I am blaming you
again you're probably a young guy you
never had this so you learned your
lesson here
um
I don't know dude like if if
secretly wearing a recording device
you know
makes you feel more comfortable and then
I I
don't have a problem with it
I mean dude do you I don't know if you
ever heard like what happens to rapists
in in jail
uh you know they're like hunted down
and gang raped and all of that
type of it's horrific what
could have happened to you just because
she said that that happened
and um
those feminist groups that are doing
that I mean they've basically
exposing themselves
for what they truly are
is they're sexist
they're totally sexist any woman
says a guy does anything they just
totally have their back
they don't give a I mean if this
was this person even in that year said
that you know someone raped and didn't
raped her and didn't I mean right there
they did a little bit of where
they just immediately back them let me
guess did they apologize to you at all
you know I'm sure they didn't
did they as big as a surge that
they did online or wherever they were
coming at you when they apologized which
should have been even bigger did they
I'm sure they didn't
you know because there's sexist
they are they don't give a they sit
there and they pat themselves on the
back like they're these socially
Advanced people and they aren't
they're the exact thing that
they're fighting the exact sexist
guy that thinks a woman should just be
there to suck his dick and make him a
sandwich they are the female version of
that
they are the female version that
generally speaking and I can
speak in generalities considering how
they treated you
um all right here we go
Italian guitarist he's bad hey Billy
Bonzo bill I love you and I need your
help all right I am a 16 year old guy
from Egypt
that's so cool and you listen to
this podcast that's awesome yes you have
fans in Egypt anyway I have been playing
guitar for two years now and I started a
band with some friends that's awesome a
drummer a bass player and another guitar
player here's the problem we're having
trouble with the guitar player he is
flashy he is a flashy with no
Talent he never practices enough has
very bad quality guitar and amp learn
solos only and doesn't even play them
correctly and he wants me to play the
Rhythm Section while he shits the lead
parts I don't have a problem in playing
Rhythm but only if he can play well to
put his failure into perspective he's
been playing guitar for over six years
and most people tell me I'm way better
than him not trying to be cocky or
anything just on him more and
more uh where I live finding another
guitarist who can actually play is very
difficult so it's hard to let him go
while we have a gig coming in October so
should we let him go and find another
guy and and if so can we tell him that
he is out
Jesus Christ dude there's a lot of
variables in this one all right so if I
aim to believe that this guy stinks as
much as you do
and not that this is some
cliched in band fighting where you're
playing Rhythm and he's playing lead so
all the chicks want to bang him
afterwards and you're standing there
like what about me
you know what I mean
everyone wants to Angus nobody
wants to Malcolm over here
you know
um as long as it isn't that this guy
truly does suck and if you're actually
better than him then
um
why don't you turn yourselves into a
power Trio
you know and then all you got to do is
have your bass player and your drummer
will give them more space for when
you're playing the lead
um it would make you a better guitarist
too especially if there's some space
within those leads and then you can hit
a couple of the Rhythm chords
then go in and out of the make
you a better guitarist
I mean I can tell you right now
that if you think this guy's a flashy
with no talent and he's not
practicing and he's been playing three
times as long as you and you feel that
you're better I don't see you guys ever
coming to a point where you're going to
be happy with what the he's doing
um my only question is though you do
need some Showmanship in the band I
would think
because sometimes somebody can be better
than somebody else but they stand there
and they look like a toad
waiting for a fly to come by and then at
that point you literally have to be a
musician to understand how
what they're doing because there is you
know you also have to entertain people
so uh
all his flashy though that could
get you some gigs
you know what I mean in the beginning
who knows I don't know
you you would have to assess all of that
but if you the drummer and the bass
player are all on the same page you just
think this guy's a flashy who's
who's not bringing anything to the band
then uh then yeah I'd bounce the guy
maybe after you gig in October if
there's not enough time to find somebody
new maybe play one more gig and
then get rid of them
um but if if he's actually
you know there's been a lot of flashy
guys that couldn't quite play
but they were fun to watch and the bands
made it
so I don't know
that that part of it is going to have to
be up to you
but uh I think there's opportunity there
for you to become an even better
guitarist if you want to try to hold
down his parts for a while
until you find somebody else and then
you know what you only have to split the
gig money three ways instead of four
all I would say is if you're going to
start playing leads then uh I would
steal a little bit of that guy's moves
in his fashion scent you know what I
mean
you got to do a couple of things
you can't be standing back dead
I don't
like I said like that Toad on a lily
path all right uh Canadian politician
wants to stunt population growth a
broccoli bill just saw this article
about Elizabeth May the leader of of our
green party the number four uh political
party in Canada who supports reducing
the world's population uh figure it's up
your alley that's amazing uh here's a
link to her party platform but since you
suck at reading here are a few of the
main points of what she wants to do
that's hilarious I was even struggling
reading that sentence uh one integrate
goals for reduced fertility in the
overall effort to eliminate poverty
uh what does that mean
she wants to sterilize poor people
uh this does not sound green this sounds
like brown shirt uh realize that failure
to stabilize and reduce human population
will result in the inevitable reduction
of human population by means of high
death rates as the Earth's human
carrying capacity is not only exceeded
but reduced by the consumption of
resources and the destruction of
biological Capital resulting in poverty
starvation disease great human suffering
and possibly social disruption
absofucking lutely
check all of those off
uh integrate goals from improved health
care and spreading knowledge of birth
control methods and efforts that
increase the availability of birth
control equipment and supplies into the
overall efforts to eliminate poverty
four recognize that the high level of
per capita resource consumption in
developed countries makes the impact of
their population much more serious
stoked to see you in Toronto for a
couple weeks just Just For Less and
thanks for the podcast you dope
um well speaking of stupid you're gonna
see me next week unless this is
left over from a while ago uh you
actually can see me this week so it's
not a couple of weeks what I think needs
to be done
is I think that there just needs to be
from top to bottom information
on what the human population is doing
to the oceans to the air to the trees to
all of that type of and at this
point it's not this is not even tree
hugger this is just literally fact
um there just needs to be way less
people and if you just
like I was going to say prognosticated
is that actually a word if you just
projected if you just showed what the
we're headed towards
and you scared the out of people
and you somehow
this is why it's not going to work you
got to get everybody on the same page
and you got to get people to not
uh act selfishly it's like if there's a
plane crash right
into the mountains
and the survivors are sitting there and
they pulled together all the resources
they have
and they're all on the same team no
matter what there's always going to be
that person who's out for themselves
okay and that's just in a group of
20 people so if you just factor
that in into 7 billion people
the amount of people that are out there
for themselves
um I don't think that it works
and I think that we are uh we are doomed
to
to that second paragraph
where there's uh
you know was resulting in poverty
starvation disease great human suffering
and possible social disruption I think
that that's going to happen I think the
upper one percent realizes that and I
think they're insulating themselves
um from that inevitability by pooling
the resources for themselves turning
places into police States getting rid of
Rights and living in gated communities
they are all set
all right they are all set for all of
that to happen
um
and that's just my paranoid two
cents um anyways
so that's the podcast here for this week
um I'll send you that that video of the
porpoises swimming through the ocean
while they're still there and uh
what else
I think that's it I gotta oh yeah so I
gotta run of dates this week man if
you're in Texas all right I'm going to
be in Austin for two shows tonight I'm
going to be in San Antonio I'm going to
be in Dallas I'm going to be in Houston
um is that it I think that that is it no
El Paso on this run no College Station
no Corpus Christi none of that so
you know you might have to drive a
little bit but I'm driving all over the
Heart of Texas
and um and on Sunday I'm going to be at
the Just for Laughs in Toronto
I got a whole new hour of
I am rested up sort of from my um
my uh my week out there in Nantucket and
I'm not really rusted up I smoked a
cigar every day I smoked two on
one day
and I am spent but
that'll give me fuel for my stand-up act
so anyways uh
I think that's it that's the podcast go
yourselves I will talk I'll check
on Thursday see you
everybody and welcome back to the
anything better podcast NFL Edition week
number three with your host me Paul
verzi over here Bill Burr over there we
got the Greek Freak in Greece doesn't
get more Greek than that and then we got
Jake The Snake Ross Jake The Snake
Rothstein over in uh
you know you don't want to get the look
from Jake The Snake when you make your
cake you don't want to see him be like
yeah like we don't even know where Jake
is located look at him he looks like
he's in some cave with stats he's got a
white board
it's got cinder blocks around they call
them the algorithm
yeah he's our he's our Jonah Hill from
Moneyball yeah you guys are listening to
uh the third week of our NFL thing oh
Paulie had a rough one what can I say
but before we get into before we get
into that let's talk about our great
sponsor betmgm uh love working with
these guys all you guys have to do you
know it by now if you listen to the show
all you got to do you place your first
bet the BET MGM Sportsbook wager through
bet MGM Sportsbook mobile application at
least ten dollars guys all you do is you
put ten dollars in you'll receive 200
instantly in additional winnings
regardless of your wages outcome uh how
do you do it four easy steps you
download the BET MGM app uh you sign up
and deposit ten dollars at least ten
dollars into the newly created account
you place a wager in the amount of at
least ten dollars at standard odds price
which is a qualifying bet and once you
have placed a qualifying bet you receive
200 bucks in bonus bets regardless of
the outcome of your wager we will also
um yeah and we're also going to be doing
the they're still doing the Survivor
pool it's not for the grand prize of
250k but you could sign up anytime keep
picking the team you think is going to
win and I'm sure there's going to be
some prizes right Andrew just not the
250k so you guys can still sign up for
that it's not too not too late for that
and of course what happened to the 250
Grand
I was well you don't have to act like
Paul that's like when we got that
first down
and then they go to the replay Booth the
guy's not laying on the
he's laying on open grass with
with lead-based tires on it that
that causes cancer but we don't we
refuse to acknowledge it here in
the United States
how the with Andrew you're a
Patriots fan you're unbiased
I can't go to you Jake The Snake
I gotta ask you dude what the about
that was more conclusive than what the
guy said on the field
of course Collinsworth was like I don't
get that call
to tell yeah
yeah
well I didn't want you guys all to agree
with me now there's nothing to yell
about all right we got hoes last
week I think well no I think the nose I
think the nose of the ball was at the
marker I saw it I think it was
they should have let that go they should
have left this is what I think I don't
think anybody could tell the ref took a
guess and the goddamn replay
didn't show anything either way so you
go with what you said on the field
nah you can't tell me that for
years
and then then it's time for my team
you're like yeah that rule
is there anything holding that football
like a woman that jumped off a fire
escape with their baby you couldn't even
see the thing
is there anything better than Bill Burr
yelling about the Patriots with that old
school amazing starter jacket on I mean
the special teams coach in 1982. what
the hell is going on out there Bill all
you need to do is throw the headset when
you're done oh that's our new expression
instead of keep your shirt on Andrew the
new expression is hey don't don't throw
your headset keep your headset on I
would stop
[Applause]
um all right we'll do a quick recap I'll
do a recap real quick of mine and then I
will pass it to you but before we get
started we always want to say here at
the anything better podcast guys we're
doing this for fun and we want you guys
to bet responsibly have a good time with
it enjoy the weekend and don't
let it be some crazy thing okay we
always want a ten dollar buy-in ruin
your life here you're supposed
to have fun this is just silly that
we're doing here don't forget you know
more than you know tens of thousands of
dollars Paul then I think you'd have to
be a millionaire to do that
right well no it's stupid here it's like
when you go to the convenience store and
you want a little you're a little
thirsty Grandpa grab a sixer you don't
grab a 30 case on a Tuesday on sports
ball you're dating a stripper don't fall
in love with her all right don't chase
her down the Street she's gone
you know if we play back if we play back
last week's picks I said this on the Pod
I go I looked at my card and I go I
don't know guys I go I don't love this I
go this is something that could be good
or Owen for and then I watched the Lions
up a touchdown all of a sudden it says
overtime then I watched the Chargers up
for covering over time then I'm going oh
boy then Jimmy Garoppolo he's throwing
picks all over the yard to the
bills now I'm going Paul he's got 0-3
and then my Giants who are getting
absolutely skunked 20 to nothing after
going the Giants went down 60 points to
nothing the first two games of course we
come back and Paulie loses that one too
oh bill I did the unimaginable and
weakness grab my paw could you sleep
with your picks the unforgivable but I
could but I could that's why
I love that you know I why I beat the
book I can sleep I can sleep with my
picks that like made no sense in total
sense at the same time like you you
split the Matrix I don't even
know what that means but I'm going with
it uh and Bill at least you know what
was nice for you I was talking to bill
and it's always nice when you know you
got two wins in your back pocket before
the late games because you were just now
when you get on the last two
games but thank God yeah they call rough
in the passer one more time on
that drive against the Jets Paul
the guys were literally in the air that
Prescott was taking I could have
taken that hit my Street close I
would have limped around a little bit
but I still would have made it into
Staples to buy some coffee or paper
dude if you took that hit you would not
be on this podcast right now get the
out of it I've seen homeless guys
tackle innocent people out here in L.A
and they've shaken it off more than that
give me a break
all right we're coming right out of the
gate Paul
you know my jacket's on so you know what
I'm gonna be taking later on oh I gotta
guard that and I know Paul you're too
much of a gentleman to take that
thing from me so this is what I'm gonna
do Paul
uh I think the Colts have a terrible
defense according to what I saw by the
way Paul uh the new Inside The NFL is
amazing
I watched it last night it's four guys
that played the game that know the game
breaking it down for an hour it's
fantastic I was on the NFL Network and
I'm watching this show there's some dude
and some lady the guy's voice
was higher than hers there was no
testosterone on the show I thought they
were remodeling a kitchen I was like
dozing off like are they talking about
football here and then they put on
NBC ABC
they got
they got old Joe Cinco on there they got
a dude from the Redskins and two other
guys that played the game
they're talking yeah you know whenever I
played the Steelers it was a double chin
strap game that was the kind of it
made me feel more like a man I recommend
that show
um all right I'm gonna go with the
Ravens I loved what I saw last week they
got this dude Gus Edwards dude just a
a monster running back uh uh um
Lamar Jackson's throwing the ball better
than I've ever seen him he's running
around like a deer you think
he's taking off he throws the ball you
think he's throwing the ball he
takes off Clowney's coming into his own
with this little skip step going around
people I know they're laying guess what
Paul I don't give a I'm taking
agents
updated line on that bill is seven and a
half seven and a half I like you even
better by the way
the injury
report no I mean we're Flying Blind in
here with Falcon instruments
um
food chains what do you got I like that
I like that pic Ravens look good and
Ravens look like they're gonna keep
getting better they're one of those
teams that's going to keep getting
better
um here's the deal dude is Joe burrow
definitely out
Joe Pearl had that gun on his
cap he uh celebrated a touchdown and I
think he tweaked it and he was literally
at the end of the game came out limping
and uh you know you know the guy's the
man he smokes cigars he played
at LSU I mean he's going to give it his
all on Sunday but uh
you know
guys calf is definitely an issue
Hey Jake The Snake we have that report
that's a definite he's out it's not
definite but uh Jake your rest is
Tangiers what are they saying over there
unlikely is what I would say but it's
really likely yeah
reptilian Tony your voice this week I
would go with that unlikely Paul
and the Rams have covered the last two
weeks the coverage and I always win it
with a cover oh yeah you guys see yeah
and that's a big thing for that coach
too covering kicking that field
goal
what the was that Paul I thought
that was to cover the spread that was
for a push
yeah look at that guys the best looking
coach in the NFL no disrespect to Pete
Carroll he held the title for a long
time it's now that dude with the
Rams
he has this guy kick that field
goal Paul I'm not trying to get in your
head
it's a push the amount of money that he
made Vegas
he's a 50-minute flight away from Vegas
Paul you tell me he wasn't with some
Showgirls that night
doing a little Chorus Line High stepping
you know I'm wearing it's under armor
wear what I liked all week what I liked
all week
and I'm sticking to it I'm sticking to
it I liked it all week and here's why
you know you got an 0-2 Bengals team you
can't go oh and three at home and they
have too much talent with Joe Mixon and
Chase okay I don't know who the I don't
know what's gonna happen with burrow but
since it's not a definite they're laying
two and a half Cincinnati season is on
the line at home and I don't trust the
Rams just the fact that they kicked the
field goal down to cover I don't like
what's going on there uh and I I'm going
to take the Bengals at home minus two
and a half to win the game by three I
got Cincinnati at home
I bet a lot of people don't agree with
that so I think that that's a good pick
because you know somebody I don't know
who the Rams are I don't know
what's going on over there and it's two
and a half right now even better fuel
pump I like it at two and a half wait I
used to it two and a half but you're
laying two and a half no the Bengals got
to win by three they gotta win by three
you know
Joe Burrows not going on three
he's not going out with three I like
that all right here's another team I
like Paul this is a crazy game
um
oh I got two Crazy Ones Paul I'm sitting
I'm teetering at least like I'm on a
seesaw here uh
I think I'm gonna take my Titans
you love him he's getting three dude the
Titans to you are the Chargers to me
no except mine come through yeah that's
true you're gonna go to organization
dude the charges man the Chargers are a
dysfunctional family they got a bunch of
talented kids there but there's no
parental supervision too hard at it
correct
and that's minus three you're right bill
the Titans are minus three
you just cut out on me can anybody hear
me they're getting angry yeah they're
getting three all right so the Titans
are laying three against the Browns I'll
tell you this
no no they're getting three they're
getting three I'll tell you this slide
nobody gave many respect on on on uh
Monday night against the
Steelers DeShaun Watson was throwing
some great balls he was throwing some
great balls he was moving around
to turn around the ball a lot they
obviously lost Nick Chubb which is
brutal but they're gonna get
what's his face is coming back
the guy was blocking on punts there in
the hotel room there Kareem uh
hunt I'm taking the Titans I think
they're a good goddamn organization and
uh I don't know I'm sick of
betting on the Browns until they get
their together
they me again on Monday night so
I'm a little jilted jilted lover here
I'm taking the Titans getting three
against the Browns in Cleveland
nice I like that that's a good pick
all right here we go we got two oh man
this is not stood this is I mean this
one made me lose some sleep
this is the one where you look you stare
down yourself in the mirror after Owen
four and you go we gotta get back up on
his horse
I like your pick so Paul wait so far
Paul what do you got
the Owen two Chargers are going to the
0-2 Vikings
okay the oh and two Chargers are going
to the 0-2 Vikings in Minnesota and the
line is basically a pick em
it is a one-point spread for the
Chargers so Vikings getting one at home
whoever goes down is I mean this is
tough
here's the deal
I'm gonna do something I didn't think I
would do I'm gonna take the Minnesota
Vikings at home wow
against the Chargers Justin Jefferson is
a the best wide receiver Jake why are
you shaking here you don't like it
no I'm just a fan
you're a fan of the mic
yeah yeah sorry okay I'm sorry uh
look it's a pickum it's a one point game
I think whatever T would be home with
this one point spread win the game
uh as much as like the Chargers dude I
think the Vikings at home with the with
the talent they got and the charger
should have won that game last week I
mean they are going to be pissed oh it's
like a Pick Em I'm just gonna take
Minnesota Kirk Cousins putting I mean
putting up like he's put up like 350
yards a week at this point I mean he's
he's playing really really really well I
just think listen I just think the home
team and the Chargers just have broke my
heart man and I wanted them so bad I'm
gonna I'm gonna take Minnesota to watch
this is the Year this is the week the
Chargers turning around I got to
Minnesota Vikings at home getting one
point with their season on the line in
front of their fans
all right I like that you know Paul
every other game I like
if the spread is just too goddamn big
you know I hate that 49ers game tonight
Giants what four days rest 49ers
couple days rest there
10 and a half I'm staying away
from that that Cowboys thing the Cowboys
look
incredible
um I'm buying into them now
I thought the 40 to nothing thing was
that was just some weak one or
whatever but like that they are a
serious Real Deal team with the coach
and all of that but that spread 12 and a
half I don't like that so Paul
um
the next closest game that's really
catching my freckle night
um Eagles minus five and a half first
Banker Mayfield Jalen hurts he's got
that number one receiver plus that uh
DeAndre Smith kid you know with the
Chris Tucker voice he's
hilarious he's like a six foot he's got
a little Randy mossisms in them
um I just think that they got too much
on defense and on offense I know that's
a lot of points
but I I feel like uh Tampa's been
playing a little above what everybody
thought I think they come down to earth
this week I think the Eagles put a
hurting on them and establish themselves
you know with a nice little Showdown
coming in who's going to be better in
the NFC uh East there the Cowboys and
the Eagles I like it they I think they
just have too much
that the Eagles man they got like like
top tier explosive speed
and I don't know I just don't think that
I don't think Tampa's defense is going
to be up for it so I'm taking the Eagles
minus five and a half going into Tampa
going in Ybor City
and The Improv down there and walking
away with some strippers
talk about two of the best wide
receivers in football on the same team
with AJ Brown and Devonte Smith dude
that's that's ridiculous DeAndre at
Devonte I'm sorry Devante Smith I can't
I can't get any of these these
new school names Paul I you know
um
all right I got another one that I
didn't think black guy names now have
more syllables than Italian guy last
names
[Laughter]
yeah when I was a kid it was like
Haywood Leon it was they were they was
they were more so yeah white guy could
get it this this like DeAndre
Dion said there's like 47
offshoots to that now I'm never
gonna get it straight it's like the NHL
once the Russians got in I can't
I can't pronounce I can't pronounce a
defenseman's name anymore those
Finnish guy
some guy from Helsinki he could have a
20-year career in the NHL I'm going by
his nickname
yeah that is so true and there's so many
devontes that Devonte Smith uh what's
his name on the Devonte Adams that wide
receiver uh oh that's this all I
whatever is something Smith
no disrespect I'm old all right
that that kid can play
speaking of something Smith that'll lead
me into this next pick I'm picking a
team that I rarely pick
I'm gonna take the Seattle Seahawks at
home
minus six against the Carolina Panthers
Carolina's got a rookie quarterback from
Alabama he looks like he's going to be
good and he's calm kid but I just think
Sneaky Pete at home with uh you know
Sneaky Pete at home they're one and one
they need to win Geno Smith is showing
that he's definitely more than just uh
game manager and I love that it's minus
six and not seven on a Wednesday
afternoon
so I'm gonna take I'm gonna take the
Seattle Seahawks minus six at home
against a young Carolina Panthers team I
like that pick and I hope Gino Smith you
know you know last week he was just you
know as a kid say he's balling out like
I don't think he that's one of his best
games as a pro and I I really like that
guy and I hope that's more to come I
hope they're going in that direction
that that just wasn't uh
you know
a fluke or whatever a good week because
everybody's always on that guy
and I think he's a solid dude on
and off the field all right Paul and
with that the end there's a reason I
wore the jacket Paul there's a reason I
wore the jacket I'm taking my New
England Patriots
my New England Patriots Paul
lay in three
going down to the Giant's house that the
Jets rent
all right I watched that kid
Zach Wilson cannot throw to the back
shoulder
okay it's receivers were open a couple
of times against it then my glasses are
crooked just like my personality
my I I just I'm telling you I
like the Pats we're gonna get our first
win our defense is ranked like fourth to
fifth in the league nobody's talking
about that
um I think the offense finally steps up
and starts playing at Bill Belichick
level football
um I kind of like you know Ezekiel
Elliott Ezekiel Elliott hasn't done
anything quite yet I think he does I'm
hoping he's gonna be our Corey Dillon
like back in the day you know when
everybody thought Corey Dillon was done
on the Bengals we brought him in big
game Corey Dillon great announcement
great analogy
that was good bill it's actually uh the
line moved on that so good news the Jets
are only getting two and a half
so a field goal will give you yeah
I think it changed the minute you put
the sunglasses on I think it changed the
mini and put the sunglasses I don't know
I don't know I think maybe this is a
correlation Andrew you know Vegas knows
I can move on with how I dress I can
make it go
one way or the other
uh all right Paulie
Jake can you do me a favor here can you
tell me the two my God he's found in a
friend no Jake can you tell me the two
teams
that the Falcons beat in week one and
two
uh Carolina and Green Bay
okay
that just that just affirms what I'm
thinking here because look I do love
I do love the 2-0 Dolphins playing the
0-2
uh Broncos and you know what else and I
do like the Saints over the Packers uh
in Green Bay but you know what I like
stay away from that State's offense dude
they suck in the Red Zone all right let
me finish I gave you your you
put your glasses on I'm trying to help
you out here all right I'm not going
there you didn't let me finish I had a
nice little uh Christianity Paul
Paul you're right I'm sorry wait was it
a crescendo is a crescendo that they're
right I don't anyway look yes yes
but you made the rowing the boat motion
so I thought you were rowing to your
answer though no no I went like this
I gotta see it I gotta see it so this is
a sleep at night bet I'm taking it
I'm taking
I I gotta do it I'm taking the lions at
home three minus three and a half
against the Falcons who
yeah I thought you were going fast to
what the is we talk about the
Falcons being good who's that kid they
got a running back yeah but who did they
play dude they played Carolina they
played they played two rookie
quarterbacks
and they were doing like some little uh
comparisons with their videos
on the the great new lineup of inside
the NFL that's going to be my go-to
uh the Lions have a sick defense man and
if if any team can stop a run it's the
Lions the Lions lost a heartbreaker in
overtime at home after the big
feeling good about Kansas City win on
opening night I think the Lions put it
on the Falcons I actually can we do one
thing first before you put a
stamp on that can we bring up a picture
of the Falcons head coach
you got to see this guy Paul
the second I saw him I was like I
love this guy and I love the
Falcons
like I'm watching them this week on
YouTube if I can figure out how to dude
is there anything harder than
trying to get that thing to work
confirm where you are in your phone you
got to go into your settings
yeah I'll drop I'll drop a picture and
uh in post as they say but uh for Paul
all intents and purposes it
can you zoom in on that stash
[Music]
is that he looks like an In-Shape club
soda candy soda Kenny yeah he looks like
Kenny's cousin dude I don't know what it
is about that dude that stash in that
face but I believe in that guy
I'll be honest with you that picture
that picture that's what I'm talking
about dude that that guy looks like a
loser and I don't mean like I
don't mean in life I mean like in
football
that that made me want the Lions more oh
I got the line but anytime a guy's doing
this
come on dude that's the picture
I mean his defense probably did
something stupid there I'm telling you
Paul you got to see that man in action
Andrew put up Dan Campbell put up Dan
Campbell's picture
with his hands on top of his head that
was a bad picture man come on
Paul if I did all of my picks like this
you would think I didn't know what I was
talking about
[Laughter]
Paul this is how special this code is
I've never worn it outside I still love
the tag on it ah I save it for
the special week dude I'm betting on
that guy look at the intensity of that
guy I know what I guess that's your ego
Paul you you think in your head you are
that guy but you're more the Falcons
coach
I've got to do a third show
ah
ah there's a midnight uh I don't know
man that guy I'm telling you the Lions
coach looks like he still has time to
work out
that other guy's eating wings until four
in the morning and donuts
looking at game film
look I'm sticking to it Lions minus
three and a half they're gonna put it on
the Falcons this week all right Paul
keep your headset on all right I don't
need to get all upset with me here
hold on a second Andrew so I got let me
just re-uh I got the Bangles
yeah
you got the Bengals uh minus two and a
half the Vikings plus one
the Seahawks minus six and the Lions
minus three and a half
I like Paulie's picks you know what Paul
when you line them all up
when you line them all up Paul I think
I'm gonna sleep better
okay hey did I tell that joke I said
that I said the Nia last week when she
was she was from Plants her time in the
month she was complaining about cramps
and I'm watching football all day no
that's so funny because I got to sit
down I got crab sleep bad I go MIA you
got your period you don't have a
separated shoulder
[Laughter]
oh I wish that was on the podcast she
cursed me out so bad I started laughing
and she started laughing and that's why
I married her how many how many women
can take that joke Paul come on
I mean that's a tough one that's great
she she she and me she goes
you and I just started laughing and then
she immediately laughed and then it was
it Paul you just show her a video of
Nick chubb's leg dude Nick chub dude
gotta be with that cow was one of the
worst hits leg wise I've seen man
hearing that dude screaming in pain was
brutal man yeah that kid on
Miami you ended up signing with the uh
the bills and had a great career too um
oh oh Willy and again uh no Willie
McGahey yeah Willis
mcgay he had a good career with the with
the um Patriots bills and he also played
for the Patriots but he also played for
the Ravens
yeah no he had a great career
on draft day picked up the phone and
called him and acted like teams were
talking to him and he got him in there
one of the great moves at all
time and his scummy is the owners
probably thought that was he did them
all a favor because that guy was
great
um so
real quick
Aaron Rodgers and Nick
and Nick most entertaining guys
I love the Browns dude he's as much as
they annoy me that's why I'm
betting against them this week
read I'm gonna read down Bill's
pics real quick just for the record I
know what I got I got the patch for the
listeners
Raven's minus seven and a half Titans
minus three eagles minus five and a half
Patriots getting two and a half and we
got two games for the Monday night
special you can choose from Eagles add
bucks bucks are getting five and a half
Bill already picked uh wait slow down so
I'm minus Evan with the Ravens I'm plus
two and a half with the Pats minus five
and a half with the Eagles
oh Titans are plus three yeah times a
plus three but the Patriots are getting
two and a half they are
yeah oh my God against um
I feel good about that
I felt good about that all right that's
a lock dude that's uh all right bill
it's time for you to sing Bud oh let the
mundane not special
win some money for you let the Monday
night special
when some money for you we
almost had it last week literally they
were right down at the goal line when
that awful injury happened and we had
Nick Chubb the score to touchdown wait
can I just say something people that
listened to the show actually write in
and go I listening to Bill's signal
Monday night special is one of my
favorite things series we were looking
good in the first too but are we gonna
do the Eagles and bucks or are we gonna
do the Bengals and uh like I mean uh
Bengals and chargers
I'm sorry Bengals and rims Bengals and
Rams I want to stay away from the bank
of rams because
where Joe burrow is that
all right Jesus Christ what do you got a
harem going on over there
every time I hear it is you got a
different broad you got broads going you
can't you can't have it
Jake we can't have it
sorry Dr Dre over here I thought they
wouldn't go through
Jesus Christ
all right
just a bunch of women going up to Jake
with lines hey dude they changed he's
got he's got a child they're
bringing the numbers in no he's one of
the quietest Dawns that ever ran
a casino they got the perfect honest
unassuming guy and all of a sudden he
gets on our podcast and they say they're
gonna tear down the trump in
Vegas I don't think that that's a
coincidence he's like Remo in
Casino nobody had Oklahoma
[Laughter]
nobody had Oklahoma he's going to be
hosting his own talk show by the end of
the week
because you see him he's making us a lot
of money and we want him to continue to
make us a lot of money
Eagles bucks
is what we want
um what do you think Bill AJ brown or
you want to go with your boy you
mentioned your boy Devon uh Dion what's
his name Smith and now I you up
well it's not DeAndre it's Devonte
Devante Smith my my my apologies
and devantes I mean you know
white tank I'm too white tape
over here bill you think you're thinking
training camp he goes all right we need
all the devontes on the right and
DeAndre is on the left
and then the field goal kickers get all
the billies and Bobby's over there
they don't even name white guys Bill and
Bob anymore I have like a my
name's gonna be like Ebenezer if I live
long enough oh okay all right um
I'm going I like the eagles I like the
eagles uh
I like uh Jalen hurts is gonna throw one
he's got too many weapons there even if
they take away the number one option
they gotta they got enough they got a
1.5 option
and Mr Smith I'll call him that Mr Smith
Goes to Tampa Paul
gonna catch one deep over a
cornerback so that's my first thing
um
so there you go over under no there you
go you just said it we get the uh we
could take the
the eagles with the spread
what's his name to throw one and what's
his name to catch one right
Jalen hurts and Devonte
what like who's the number one receiver
AJ Brown
I think AJ let's go with AJ I like AJ I
think AJ gets one
I love it
I like that we went conservative we
didn't try to get cute this week
beast mode we didn't try to throw it get
a interception
our picks are in but let's just take two
minutes two minutes here to talk about
this other game this game these games
with the big lines the two big lines are
obviously nobody's believing in the
bears but I would I'm curious and I know
people think I'm nuts
the Giants head coach just says saquan's
actually a lot better he might be
playing on Thursday I'm wondering if the
10 points with the Giants is like
everybody thinks the Giants are going to
get blown out and they're coming off
that win and everyone's like oh you know
but it was against Arizona
I don't know dude 10 points is a lot in
the NFL what do you think about that you
think the Giants are getting lose by
more than that
I would stay away from the Giants I
don't know what the they're gonna
do yeah other than go I mean I mean are
you impressed after two weeks full
I've never seen anything like that you
can't trust them they're just like let
up almost 100 points in two
goddamn games and you came back against
the Cardinals but you know the Cardinals
stink now you're going up against you
know one of the best teams in in the uh
the NFL
um I you know 10 points is a lot I
always feel like on those games
they actually they start covering and
then they take their foot off the gas
and you get the back door cover I hate
that game
yeah I hate that game I would stay away
from that game Paul like I would stay
away from a
I don't know
the hooker well Billy's bill is
500 right now at even and probably I'd
stay with me four games I'd stay away
from a hooker after Super Bowl weekend
how about that you don't know what's
flying around down there
all right I mean in case you but what if
you won big money
Paul what if for once you didn't bet
with your heart
last week you bet on the Raiders because
they had an Italian under Center
and you knew you went against your
gut Paul
you had a good team coming off the loss
going at home
and all you saw was a big bowl
of goddamn ziti and you jumped all over
it I mean he's a good looking Italian
kid what do you want me to do what you
can lay off
it was a football game Paul it wasn't A
Bronx Tale
I got Tony C
Tony C I got what the points uh
here's an NFL trivia question who is the
last badass
Italian wide receiver in the NFL
because the only one I could think of
wasn't even a receiver it was Mark
Bavaro who was the first name I thought
of he was a tight end though he was a
tight end there was no I don't know any
Italians that just ran posts you
guys can't lay off the bread you can't
make weight at the wide receiver
you know you have to after 25 you're
gonna be a tight end it'll come in on
blocking Downs yeah they're like dude
bartolucci just ran a five two four
three we gotta cut him
let's see Sarah gusta rest his soul rest
his soul yeah a lot of tight uniforms
with the uh the vowels well the Bosa
Brothers Nick and Joey Bosa are there
but they're they're defensive their
animals but their defensive ends oh dude
come on dude those those are that's
Mediterranean Italian I'm talking
American Italian those guys got they
look like they're sipping a cappuccino
after they kick your ass out
there dude how to love the poster
Brothers oh dude they're they're
hilarious dude uh Hey Frank
and the Foster Brothers
oh scary those cockroaches yes
um what the hell was I just gonna say oh
dude how about the Knicks getting that
shooter talk about a baller
who's Italian Dante D Vincenzo is on the
Knicks kid's a shooter too
I mean here's the thing he's Italian
with red hair he's an Italian red hair
kid shoots the lights out one two
national championships with Villanova
to make
I didn't hear what Andrew said what'd he
says
[Laughter]
Paula baby made it to the Knicks
and he kept his hair
no I'll be honest with you man this way
they only drafted him because I knew
Paul was going to buy enough jerseys
today used to make payroll like an
Italian kid oh dude I'd be out in Little
Italy passing off the back of a truck
who wants a divincenzo got a fifty
dollars I got a hundred fifty dollars
off
uh oh dude can you still see me Bobby
Kelly's calling me
um oh dude this was a fun one this is
one of the funniest ones ever I I hope
everybody enjoyed uh enjoyed our picks
uh bill you know Bill's picture you know
my picks Monday night special Jalen
hurts to throw one AJ Brown to catch one
Philadelphia Eagles to cover over the
Tampa Bay Bucks with that line is five
Andrew
and you know what the best thing about
this game is going to be Paul
so I don't have to listen to him
once again tell me how to order a
Philly cheesesteak
sandwich
yeah uh most of the money's actually
going to the bucks right now as far as
today goes 63 percent of all the money
uh is on the Bucks which is actually you
know it's good it's good to go against
the grain I wouldn't be listen I
wouldn't be in that Stadium if I was
performing in Tampa and you gave me
tickets I would not go because when you
get when you get those Philly fans that
are getting riled up against those like
low key easy going Florida fans who got
pirate hats and Slurpees and
then you got some Philadelphia think
that is not gonna go well they're coming
with Jimmy Buffett vibes yeah
um all right there you guys have it this
has been NFL picks week number three
please remember guys to go and if you
want to have fun with us and bet with us
go download the betmgm app put in as
little as ten dollar at least ten
dollars and uh you will get two hundred
dollars uh to play with regardless of
what your initial bet uh wins or loses
and just bet responsibly download the
BET MGM app use code Burr 200 that's
b-u-r-r 200 for all of these promotions
if you want to go to this uh survival
pool it's still available you can't get
the grand prize if you get in week three
because you didn't get in at the
beginning but there'll still be prizes
and you could get in pick a team and uh
if the team doesn't get eliminated you
go all the way down on the line and uh
yeah use use uh code uh Burr 200 and
also
um Andrew there's an icon on the on the
site for uh our Monday night special
you'll see uh yeah you'll see yeah when
you click yep go to the gym click NFL
the top you'll see uh the anything
better A lot of people have been uh
we'll have a convincing Victory against
an unconvincing team in the New York
Jets this week I'm telling you you can
take that to the bank Paul I love that
pick uh and that's it bet responsibly
click mine and Bill's pretty face on the
thing and get involved in our Monday
night special enjoy and we will be back
next week don't bet like a jerk off have
a good time all right now drink
responsibly all right bye guys